I'm in the box.
I'm in the box!
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Un-Metal New World!
Un-Metal New World!
Oh, I just realized the game was not... had no sound.
There it is.
Oh.
Oh, there was... I was like, wow, this game is so quiet.
It's just because I was clicked out of the window.
Hold on, let me move some stuff around on my computer real quick.
And then...
If you guys hear something in the background, it's me boiling water because I'm making drip coffee.
And if you hear something else in the background...
I don't know.
There are probably the ghosts in my room.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm just waiting for the water to boil so I can drip my coffee.
Using keyboard and mouse?
Yeah, I don't have a controller since I'm not at home.
I'm in a hotel.
So...
She has bodies in her fridge.
Yeah!
Actually, you know, hotel fridges are not very big.
So...
Unfortunately...
Ghosts other than yourself, Umin.
Of course, obviously.
I put myself in the box because I wasn't sure how...
How...
How this game will be.
I probably will block stuff, so...
Long time no where.
First time watcher of this game.
I know you will too.
Thanks!
I forgot the stream was starting.
I just heard you screaming I'm in a box from my headphones.
I wasn't screaming.
I was like, you know...
Bada!
Thanks for the 10 gift cards!
The recent delta preview shows it's faithful with only changes to graphics, aiming menus and crouching.
What do you mean crouching?
Can we crouch walk?
Because if so, huge.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I just realized the notifications.
Oh, there we go.
If we can crouch walk...
That's huge.
And Draco!
6 for the 20 gift cards!
I mean...
And it wouldn't be like weird to add crouch walking because it was in the 3DS version.
Oh, my water's done.
Hold on.
I'm gonna make some...
I've never made drip coffee before, you guys.
I bought it on a whim because I was like, wow, drip coffee.
And then also, it was like a butterscotch flavor.
So...
Okay, hold on.
Give me a second.
10% Kona coffee.
Hawaiian Paradise coffee.
That's your ASMR?
Open it.
Interaction!
What the hell is this?
I should wash this cup, actually.
Come on.
Let me wash the cup real quick.
With soap.
Hold on.
Oh, it smells really good.
This smells like good coffee.
I don't even know if you can hear me.
I might be talking to myself.
Yes, we can.
Oh, okay.
One second.
I'm making my coffee!
Wait, I haven't opened this.
Oh, it smells really good.
I'm pouring in the water.
How
much water do you need?
Ah!
My cup is too shallow.
Ouch!
You guys, my cup is too shallow.
It's not even dripping into the mug.
It's like soaking in the mug.
So...
Um...
Epic fail.
You okay?
Yeah, I ran into my suitcase.
It's like I can still hear her voice.
Oh, wow.
It smells really, really good.
I don't know how long do I have it sit for.
Oh, no!
I didn't get any cream!
I have chocolate.
I'll throw in some white chocolate.
Yeah.
I've kind of been like...
Yesterday, I really didn't do anything.
I've just been doing laundry.
Because at the last hotel that I was at...
Sakana has like expensive taste, right?
And he got this...
fancy hotel where...
there's no like communal laundry room.
The only thing you can do is...
send your laundry off to be laundered.
And...
I did it once and it was a hundred dollars!
A pair of panties!
Excuse me.
And a pair of panties is like...
300 yen.
Or... yeah.
I was like, what?
It's ridiculous.
And I can't just keep buying clothes.
You know?
I'm like...
I don't need this many clothes.
So...
You know, now that I'm at a normal person...
place.
A normal person hotel.
That has a normal laundry room.
I can do it myself.
So I've just been like...
in my pajamas all day.
Doing laundry.
It's ridiculous.
A peasant hotel.
Yeah, exactly!
But like...
Oh my gosh.
And I was like, I don't need anything special.
They like wrapped all my clothes.
And they put like...
They put like...
Oh my god, the coffee is too strong.
The smell is too strong.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's getting in my nostrils.
They put like...
You know, like a sheet of paper in between.
When they folded my clothes.
And then they wrapped it all in plastic.
And I was just like...
I don't need this.
Just make it...
Cut the price in half.
And do less the work.
I was like, no way.
This is so expensive.
So...
They sweet talk your clothes.
But it feels like they should, right?
I never ever have done laundry service at a hotel before.
That was my first time ever.
So I was like, wow.
This is unnecessary.
So now...
I'm just waiting on clothes.
And then... yeah.
So, perfect time to stream, right?
While I'm waiting on clothes.
Unnecessary.
Just like un-metal.
The game that I'm actually playing today.
I'm sorry, I keep looking over at my coffee.
Do you think it's done?
How long does coffee sit for?
Well, it's supposed to drip.
But it's soaking.
If you have too many pants...
I can help you get rid of some...
What?
Wait.
I can't tell if it's a joke or not.
A couple minutes?
Okay.
Is this a joke?
I can't tell.
lol lol lol
Oh, man.
No, luckily I brought every pair of panties I own.
So I had excess.
I'm one of those types of people.
You know?
That like, I'll bring excess socks.
I'll bring excess underwear.
But for clothes, I don't bring enough.
And so I had to go buy some stuff.
There was like... I was going to a live... I was going to... I think... Yeah, I was going to an idol show.
And especially... like usually I can wear clothes like... I don't know, like a t-shirt twice or something.
But... not in this heat?
Oh my gosh, I've been sweating like I've been coming home and my shirt and everything is just soaked with ectoplasm.
So I'm just like, the hell?
No, I'm not wearing this twice in a row.
So... so... I had to go buy more stuff.
I was just like... I was like, wait, there's no laundry room here?
Okay, I guess I'll go buy more clothes.
It's a joke.
I'm weird but with boundaries.
We all... let's say it together, everybody.
Boundaries.
Thank you for clarifying.
I really...
I appreciate it.
Weird but boundaries.
Yeah!
Weird but boundaries!
I'm very excited to play Unmetal.
Oh my gosh, it's already been 15 minutes.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
I've heard... I have known about this game for... probably since I first started playing Metal Gear.
People would be like, you need to try Unmetal.
Once you play Metal Gear, you'll appreciate Unmetal so much.
You need to play it.
It's like the best...
The best, like, parody of Metal Gear.
And I'm like, okay, I'll get around to it.
And, you know, I kind of forgot about it for a while.
And then I was like, oh, hey!
Unmetal!
Like, I need games while I'm here that I can play easily on my laptop.
So... it was my birthday yesterday.
Halfway to 70 now.
Thanks for the streams.
I really enjoy your streams.
Andreas, happy birthday!
I hope I said your name right.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Andreas.
Happy birthday!
And... did I... did my eyes deceive me?
Thank you for the 50 gift!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Finally a time to watch the face-con survive.
I just want to say, you killed it, Mint!
So fun to see you in your element like that.
Thank you!
I don't know how long the VOD will be up for.
So, um...
If you haven't watched it yet, try to...
When you can!
Alrighty.
I started a game just to kind of see...
I'm not playing with a key...
Wait, I'm a liar.
I am playing with a keyboard and mouse.
I am not playing with a controller.
So I wanted to see how the gameplay was.
How would you say I should...
Medium, right?
That's normal, right?
Medium?
Hold on, let me get my coffee.
Hold on, let me remove the drip.
Let me remove the drip.
The dev message.
What's the dev message?
Wait, I don't know that one at all.
Invisible booze!
Thank you for the $20 gift card!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
There we go.
Is it face connect coffee?
No, I literally said it's Hawaii!
I said it earlier.
Okay.
We'll do medium.
Let me get my coffee.
And then we'll try the medium.
One second.
What's that one dessert?
It's like a...
You're absurd.
Worms and dirt dessert.
It looks like that.
Where like the crumble...
Like the dirt is just chocolate.
It's like a chocolate crumble.
Do you think if I eat coffee grind raw...
I'll get sick?
I wonder.
Mud pie?
No!
You know, like the worms in the dirt.
Like it's just like they...
It's like...
It's like a Oreo crumble kind of.
And then they put gummy worms in it.
Right?
Okay, I'm gonna try this coffee.
It's...
It's really...
Hold on, did I get it?
Hold on.
I left the package over there.
And it's like a pain in the butt to leave this desk and go over there.
It's...
It doesn't say actually.
It says it's a butterscotch flavor.
But it's really strong smell.
The smell is so strong.
It doesn't say if it's like a light roast or dark roast or anything.
It just says butterscotch and I impulse bought it.
And yes, I did also buy tea.
For anybody wondering.
Yes, I only bought one thing of coffee.
And then...
And then a whole bunch of tea.
Sameer, does Minto sound a bit...
What?
Because of my cold?
What do you mean?
I know I sound a little different.
Because I'm stuffy.
Actually, I woke up and I was feeling much better today.
So...
Not as much congestion.
I haven't had to blow my nose even once.
I'm so happy.
Okay, time to...
Oh my god, the smell is really strong.
I could smell it while it was brewing.
Okay.
It's not bad actually.
The butterscotch is more of a smell less than a flavor.
Which doesn't make much sense, huh?
Those things are connected.
Okay.
Medium is premium.
Oh.
We're just getting right into it.
Whoa!
Okay.
As the pilot emerged from the wreckage, he was arrested by the same bastards who shot him down.
Oh my god.
And later was brought to a military base for interrogation.
Interrogation.
That pilot... was me.
Name?
My name is Fox.
Jesse Fox.
Fox!
You don't seem to be Russian.
Russian?
Me?
You were piloting a Russian aircraft two hours ago.
I also drive a Toyota and I'm not Japanese.
All right, mister.
Mr. Fox.
He's so sassy.
Before arresting you, I'm obligated to write down a report with your version of the facts.
So, tell us what the hell you were doing in that heavily armed Soviet helicopter.
It's a long story.
Sergeant, bring us some coffee.
Yes, sir.
That's a good thing I got coffee.
What cost you?
Bring the lieutenant some coffee.
Yes, sir.
So and so.
Well, Mr. Fox.
We have plenty of time.
Bring the lieutenant some coffee.
Explain what happened.
Mr. Fox.
In 1972, a crack commando unit threw me in a prison for a crime I didn't commit.
You're under arrest for a crime you didn't commit.
I promptly escaped from a maximum security stockade to the underground, trying to survive from these soldiers of fortune.
Thank you.
Oh, we're in the game.
Okay.
So, it's not wasp.
Let's start from the beginning.
How did you escape from that cell?
I don't know.
Piece of cake.
I just had to write a note.
A note.
Where'd you get the paper from?
I made it.
I used toilet paper.
Oh.
I see.
And how did you find a pen?
I mean, it's kind of paper, right?
A pen.
I was in a dirty, grimy cell.
Not in an office.
I wrote the note with a rusty wire.
Using my own blood as ink.
Ew.
Press X to punch.
Punch, punch, punch, punch.
Oh.
Rusty wire.
Oh my gosh.
I hope we got our shots.
Let me out of here.
Oh.
There's our toilet paper.
Press F to enter the inventory menu.
Combine items.
Combine.
I scratched my arm with the wire and got to work.
Eww.
It wasn't easy.
Okay.
The toilet paper tore under the pressure of the rusty wire.
Was he able to write this note at all?
Those bastards gave us cheap paper.
One ply, unscented and unpatterned.
Why did you break the toilet?
Why not grab the paper like a normal person?
You know how prison is.
It's kill or be killed.
So true.
And I wasn't going to be killed by some dirty toilet.
One ply.
Oh.
Hey, you moron.
Holy Jesus.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Wait.
How are we alive?
You schmuck.
Do you really think I'd be stupid enough to kill myself?
Kill myself?
Press X.
Press...
Wait.
Keep X pressed close to a flashing enemy to search him.
He may be carrying something.
Give me the key.
Yeah, baby.
Cell key.
Idiot.
Dummy.
Put him on the toilet.
Sticky.
Press...
Okay.
Go to the inventory.
We're learning.
X and C.
Nice.
Here I go.
I left the guard locked in the cell.
Then I threw away the key and got out of there.
Mr. Fox, what about the noose?
Where did you get that from?
Oh, yeah.
Where did I get the noose?
Are you seriously asking me that?
I am, Mr. Fox.
Fox.
I'll tell you later.
Press F4 to see controls of the game and then change them as you wish.
Oh, perfect.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, here we go.
Wait, so if I... F... Okay, so we don't have it anymore.
Let's see.
Yeah, the noose isn't important.
Oh!
I found myself in a prison yard surrounded by some buildings.
There were piles of boxes and other stuff here and there.
And the ground was plain dirt.
Oh, and it was night.
Search for an exit of... What did it say?
Of the prison?
Okay, so X to punch.
Gonna go over here.
Punch, punch, punch.
Oh, I actually can punch this.
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch.
Punch, punch, punch.
Oh, this is gonna cause a distraction.
You know?
It'll like... It'll like...
Explode.
Oh.
Okay, just kidding.
This looks punchable.
Aha!
And what is this?
The Great Escape.
Okay.
Oh!
Let me sleep.
Be quiet.
How's the audio, by the way?
Oh!
I can punch him, I can insult him, or I can...
I'm gonna punch him.
Oh, I think I'm dead.
Oh no, wait!
Chad is blocking my health and stuff.
It's fine, you guys.
Let's see.
How can I move the interface?
A little bit.
Hmm.
I'm gonna move...
Cause you guys are blocking the health and stuff.
And I'm sure there will be stuff down here.
Like on the bottom right, too.
Oh...
Hmm...
Sorry, you guys.
You guys are still gonna be flush to the right.
But I'm gonna put you on the left, okay?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, it looks so bad.
No!
Oh, it doesn't work!
Oh, curse my setup!
Why is it so particular?
Oh...
Oh, gosh.
Give me a second.
Hold on, let me fix this.
Ah...
Sorry, I even checked to make sure that...
No!
Oh, hold on, hold on.
...
We can do this.
I'm a genius, you guys.
I'm a professional.
...
And as for me...
I'll go right next to you guys.
Actually, I'm gonna squish myself.
...
There we go.
That should be good.
That should be better.
Probably.
Are we good now, guys?
Are we good?
...
Okay.
I think we're good.
Let's go.
Continue.
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch.
Oh, I'm still, like, blocking.
I feel like a good...
Why has my head gotta be so big?
Okay.
I didn't know that he would attack me.
...
Be quiet.
So we can punch these ones.
And we can punch these ones.
...
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, so they're reusable?
That's so nice.
Stops bleeding, doesn't recover health.
Infinitely reusable.
Let's go.
Wow.
What's in here?
We love Minto's giant pumpkin hide.
Thanks, Jax!
Oh, let me move the notice as well over... there we go, okay.
Anybody in here?
Nope.
What about this?
Oh!
Let me sleep!
Okay, not everything is punchable, I guess.
Oh, this is punchable!
Why did you keep punching those crates?
What did you expect to happen?
Nothing in particular.
Then why this gratuitous violence?
I don't know.
I suppose I got lost in the moment.
You know, for being imprisoned for a crime I didn't commit.
So true.
But also, why am I describing, like, hitting the crates and everything?
I thought everyone would be asleep at night.
That it was safe to escape.
Safe to escape.
I was dead wrong.
Oh no.
I noticed the presence of...
One?
Two?
Notice the presence of what?
One rat?
One cat?
One... Two?
Two.
Why are you guys saying two?
Pick number three, my lord.
All on two?
I guess... I mean, two is the bigger number.
So two of something would be better than one of something, right?
Two!
Two guards on the night shift.
If you're detected by a guard, he will grant no experience when you neutralize him.
I'm against the wall.
Okay.
Here's our chance to learn how to take out guards.
Wait!
But there's a little box over there.
Well, look at them walking together in tandem.
And, um... they're really good pals.
How big is their line of sight, I wonder?
Okay, hold on.
So whenever they...
turn their backs...
Oh gosh.
I feel like now would have been the perfect thing.
Metal Gear with supermassive narrator setup.
Okay, hold on.
Wow, they move really fast.
They turn around really quickly.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Don't look!
Turn around!
You jerks!
Stop looking left and right.
Now's my chance.
No it's not!
Now's my chance!
Oh my god.
You're a tough guy.
What does that radar mean?
What does that mean?
I'm scared.
Does that mean he won't be able to see me if...
he's sneezing during...
I was injured and losing blood.
Oh no.
I had to heal that wound...
before I bled to death.
Okay.
F.
And then our...
Select and use.
Choo-choo-choo-choo-choo-choo-choo-choo-choo.
Okay, all good.
What's he got?
He's got...
a handkerchief!
Oh, ew.
It's used.
Anything else?
Come here.
Let's put you...
Um...
Actually, I'm taking you with me.
Oh, I really can take him with me.
Wait a second.
Oh, he's peeing.
Okay.
See ya.
If I hit...
Can you hear this?
No, he can't.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, we're in the bathroom.
Use the toilet to save the game.
Sorry.
Oh, gosh.
No way.
That's actually how we save the game?
I'm going to do one more thing real quick, you guys.
I'm just going to...
Oh, my bad.
Hold on.
I'm trying to shrink us both together.
I want to make it just a tiny...
The game is all over the place.
So, I'm sorry.
That's like a little weird right now.
Sorry, guys.
I'm so sorry.
So sorry.
Give me a second.
Okay.
There we go.
Tiny Minto in a tiny box.
Cool.
Onwards.
There's nobody here.
Oh.
Over here.
Contact.
Contact the prisoner.
Yeah.
Hello?
You talking to me?
My name is Colonel Alan Harris.
Colonel.
I'm Jesse Fox.
Okay.
I'm not military, Colonel.
Tell me, Fox.
What the hell are you doing here?
Fox.
I've been jailed for a crime I didn't commit.
What was the crime?
I wonder.
Do you know how to get out of here?
I tried to escape through any sewer.
There must be one nearby.
A sewer, huh?
Because it stinks when it stinks.
Yeah.
What about you, Colonel?
I've been tortured.
My legs won't make it.
No, Colonel.
But if you bring me a radio.
A radio?
I can help you escape.
Okay.
Hold on.
Harris.
Are you sure you heard him say, Alan Harris?
Yes, sir.
Saw him yesterday.
It was just yesterday?
Colonel Harris died a month ago in an ambush.
Well, it's the name that stubborn old man gave me.
I see.
I'll write down on the list.
I'll write down the report that you talked to Colonel Harris after his death.
Continue your story.
The death was a cover-up.
The death was...
The death was something.
Okay.
Search for a radio for Colonel Harris.
Got it.
But also the sewer, right?
What's that?
What's this?
Continents.
What's that?
Under some crates.
I found it.
I found my salvation.
Oh, I got it.
A sewer hole.
I need Scissor 61.
There was no ladder.
I couldn't see the bottom.
Oh, no.
I needed to find a ladder or a rope if I wanted to go down.
What about the rope that we used for the noose?
You fool.
Okay, cool.
Let's go down.
A radio, huh?
Possible.
Everyone knows Colonel Harris died in that tanker two years ago.
Colonel Harris.
How do I, like, sneak up on these guys and attack them, you know?
If I, like, sneak up and hold X, I wonder if I'll, like, be able to do some big damage, you know?
Let's try.
Oh.
Oh, I got a star.
I don't know what that just did.
I got...
I took a coin off your card.
A coin?
I'm robbing this man.
What do you intend to spend it on?
I suspect there's no shops open for an escape.
Maybe on a midnight run.
Who said anything about spending?
I used it to distract soldiers.
Oh.
I quickly found out that guards love sticking out free coins off the ground.
Okay.
I got a coin.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm scared.
Mike!
Ah!
Are you okay?
Got them both.
What do you got?
A radio!
I picked up the guard's radio.
Oh.
Without encryption, I knew other guards could listen in on my conversations with Harris.
I see.
You still haven't told me how you got that noose.
Oh.
I'll tell you later.
As I was saying, I needed to find a special encryption circuit to install in the radio.
Yes.
Okay.
Attach an encryption circuit to the radio.
It's surely in here.
It's not in there.
Okay.
What about over here?
Let's check out this door since the guy was guarding it.
Seems quite important.
Oh!
God mode artifact.
What?
What does that mean?
Grants limited invulnerability when a ring is sacrificed.
What?
What does that mean?
Why is it literally gravity falls?
Oh.
Sorry.
I was pressing with Wasta again.
Press V to roll.
Okay.
Oh.
Secrets.
Oh, now we know how to roll.
We're on a roll.
Mike.
Oh no, Mike.
Press X twice over a guard to carry him.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let me sleep.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's see.
Um.
What's this guy doing up here?
I think this guy next to me will notice him.
Hmm.
Oh.
What's this guy doing down here?
How do you throw the coin?
That's a good question.
Let's see.
I think if I select it and then if I use it, it will use it, right?
Yeah.
Oh gosh.
This guy's coming around.
Wait a second.
Is this guy coming around?
Don't come around.
Oh.
Okay.
X300.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Um.
Okay.
Hold on.
How do I use it now?
Uh.
Wait.
How do I use an item?
I don't remember.
I'll figure it out.
It's fine.
Uh.
Let's go punch this guy.
Aha.
And ransack him.
Oh.
We got another coin.
And we're just gonna...
Oh.
Okay.
We're gonna pick him up.
See ya.
Okay.
We're gonna place you right here.
Can I get that thing down there?
Or...
Oh.
Uh oh.
Did he notice me?
Oh.
Shoot.
Bye.
We're not gonna get noticed today.
This is a stealth game.
Oh.
I see the little...
I've always...
I was wondering...
The little dots at the bottom were...
Um.
Were...
Just showing you to go to a new area.
I didn't realize it was showing you enemies.
Aha.
Hahaha.
I see.
Okay.
Um.
The music is like picking up.
Hey.
Give me your stuff.
What's that?
You stole a one-eyed man's patch?
A one-eyed man that would shoot you?
Shoot me without hesitation.
Yeah.
Because it was his job.
What you did was macabre.
And suggest you might have a fetish.
Holy Jesus.
Wow.
That patch turned out to be...
Not the...
Okay.
I don't need any commentary from the crowd.
Okay?
Mister?
I got an eye patch.
Maybe I do have an eye patch fetish.
I don't...
Oh my god.
I stole his eye.
What else?
You removed his glass eye too?
Um.
Suspicion.
Stress relief.
Okay.
Yes.
I took it out of his eye socket to chill out.
To chill out?
Pulling out glass eyes relaxes you?
I'm not a sadist.
I didn't enjoy pulling it out.
But it helped when I rolled it around in my mouth like candy.
I was under a lot of pressure.
Too much stress and I'd end up making a mistake.
This game is sick.
Why did it save the game though?
This is so...
This is...
This game is sick.
What's that?
Depleted uranium?
Hello?
This is another bathroom.
Hey buddy.
Oh.
I have no paper.
Can you bring me some?
I have a toilet paper.
Press F to enter the inventory.
Yeah.
Toilet paper?
And C.
It's C to use it.
I was pressing X earlier.
Okay.
There you are.
Here you are.
Thanks man.
You saved my ass.
Literally.
Yeah.
Well.
Your ass is grass.
You broke down the door and attacked a guard while he was on the toilet?
Yes.
I beat the shit out of him.
Is that a joke?
Literally.
No.
I literally beat the shit out of him.
That toilet paper wasn't unscented anymore.
Let's move on.
No.
Sir.
I'm afraid to grab that.
Oh.
No.
Destroy everything.
Nobody will have clean hands and then they'll all get sick.
Yeah.
One ply unpatterned and newly scented.
The sight of it makes you nervous.
That's the glass eye.
Sorry.
I'm covering a little bit.
Um.
Patch with elastic straps.
Can I use it?
Oh.
Now we know how mint got sick.
Stop.
That's not true.
I always wash my hands.
This is what happens when you use the eye patch.
No way.
That is so...
Oh.
Clever.
I love that.
That is so funny.
Oh.
Ma'am.
I'm with the commandos.
Fox needs to go.
Why is now my nose all runny?
Okay.
Anyway.
Let's keep going before that guy wakes up.
Okay.
Wait.
What about this guy out here?
Oh.
He's still dead.
Okay.
I mean down.
Not dead.
Oh.
This guy.
I can't.
Break the toilets?
Can I?
Can I break the toilets actually?
Oh.
I can't.
Dang.
Okay.
Here we go.
I hit the knee mode.
What are you talking about?
Oh.
All right.
Let's get this guy in.
Oh.
Let's get him good.
Hi.
Hey.
Oh.
Uranium.
What is that?
A lighter?
Okay.
I'll take it.
Evening mint.
This sure is goofy.
Mark of the ninja is highly regarded.
I see.
Thank you.
Oh.
I ran into a guard as I went in.
Ah.
Zee.
Okay, awesome.
Interesting.
Sorry guys, I gotta blow my nose.
I was doing so well the whole morning!
And then I started talking to you guys, and you activated my allergies.
I'm allergic.
A potty is a quicksave.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna mute.
It's not helping.
Gosh.
Hold on.
I didn't take any of the medicine this morning.
I'll take some right now.
Did you guys take your meds?
Be like Mito.
And take your meds.
When you should.
Oh, gosh.
It's so bad.
Bad hygiene.
Carrying other people's eyes and used toilet paper.
I only...
Wait a second.
Your name.
Made turquoise lover?
Boo!
I mean, wait.
I'm not cheering you.
Yeah!
Get out the child!
Applause, applause, standing ovation!
Hold on.
Let me do one more blow.
My nose is becoming raw.
And before you say, one nose...
But at this point...
It doesn't help at all, man.
Blowing my nose.
Before you say, one nose...
Oh, he's coming back.
What's your pattern, mister?
Where are you gonna go next?
Where are you...
Wait, I got his ass now.
I'm getting all that experience, baby.
What happens...
Oh, is this a wristwatch?
Okay.
What happens when I become level two?
Duh!
Uranium!
Bombs!
And it's for no survivors!
Is there a way to crouch in this game, I wonder?
With those first aid kits, I could disinfect and heal my wounds.
First aid!
Good news.
Those kits stopped any bleeding and also healed my wounds over time.
Oh!
Bad news.
Once you use them, they were gone.
Rip.
If I had any magic in me, I'd cast Feel Better now.
Alas, I am no maid.
Feel better soon, Minto.
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
I don't feel bad.
Just congested is all.
Like, you know how sometimes if you're congested, you get headaches and stuff like that?
Luckily, I don't feel that way.
Press X?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Woah!
Sneak attack!
That was crazy!
Oh, I got some cigarettes.
I got a snack.
Why is it always Mike?
Wait, Mike didn't have anything on him?
I'm getting a lot of uranium.
I'm exploring.
Drag them.
Knock, knock.
Who's there?
It's me, Minto.
Be quiet.
Oh, there's more down here.
Oh, this actually goes somewhere.
Oh, we have two areas we can go to.
Okay, hold on.
Let me drag.
Let me pick up this guy up.
Pick him up.
There we go.
Okay.
Now we're going to see if we can...
We did actually.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Just kidding!
Uh-huh.
All right.
There's this way.
And then what's down here?
Oh, a lot.
A lot of guys.
Hmm.
Let's go this way first.
The easy way.
Okay.
The better way.
I like the music in this.
Oh!
Hello, mister.
Hello?
Hey, bro.
Help me.
Get me out of this hole.
If you're in a cell, it's because you committed a crime.
And I don't free criminals.
But you're a prisoner, too.
I've been imprisoned for a crime I didn't commit.
Well, he didn't...
Fuck you!
Oh!
Okay.
Well, I think...
Hey, friend.
I'm also innocent.
That's what they all say.
Please, they keep the key in that box.
This...
Oh, this one?
Do you think if I use it, it disappears?
Do you think it's a one-time use?
The other one disappeared.
Also, what's this say?
Digital display for the watch.
The other one disappeared.
This is the first aid kit.
Quick saves your current game, but it's lost if you exit the game.
Interesting.
Russian.
No filter.
For the cigarettes.
Hi.
Well, now we're in a bit of a pickle, aren't we?
Oh, gross!
Needs to be emptied.
Eww!
Okay.
Well...
All right.
Okay.
I want to see what happens.
Hold on.
I'm opening it.
Thanks, dude.
You're welcome.
Don't kill me.
What a pity.
The key broke.
You bastard!
It broke!
Hasta la vista.
Oh, it saved again.
No!
It overwrote my save!
My medal!
It over...
I cannot believe it overwrote my save, so that I could...
I love when people in chat are just like, we told you, Mint, as if I see literally every single message that's going by in chat.
You guys, I'm playing a game.
I'm gaming.
You also have to just let me experience things, okay?
VTuber, why?
VTuber, I told you, VTuber, I told you that it would do.
Disappear, VTuber, and...
Hello?
The soldier says to his captain, sir, I need to request leave for this weekend.
Why do you need it, Private?
I'm going to have a baby, sir.
Congratulations.
Request granted.
Next week, the captain asks him, Private, was it a boy or a girl?
And the soldier replies, I don't know, sir.
I'll find out in nine months.
What's in your closet, Private?
It's water, sir.
Don't lie to me.
This is wine.
Praise the Lord.
That was pretty good.
Wait, tell more.
Tell more funnies.
Hey, Mike.
Oh.
Can you tell them again?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
The serge said...
Why you don't listen, VTuber?
Why?
Someone sent you a blank letter.
Oh, yeah?
The soldier says, it's from my wife, Sergeant.
How do you know that, soldier?
Because we argued and we don't talk to each other.
Wait, what?
If I were you, Minto, I would have done the same exact thing.
The soldier says to his captain, sir, I need to request leave for this weekend.
Why do you need it, Private?
Oh, is this the baby?
I'm going to have a baby, sir.
Okay.
Congratulations.
Request granted.
Oh, that was close.
Next week, the captain asks him, Private...
I'm level two!
Oh, Steel Fist, your punches strike twice against enemies in containers.
Your speed and accuracy are the same.
Your speed increases ten percent.
Probably the Steel Fists, huh?
I think the punches are better than the sprinting.
I'm actually...
I'm already kind of fast, so let's go with the Fists.
Was it a boy or a girl?
And the soldier replies...
Nothing?
I don't know, sir.
I'll find out in nine months.
What's in your closet, Private?
It's water.
It's water, sir.
Don't lie to me.
This is wine.
I reached a special place...
Oh.
...where I found something.
A special place?
What, Mr. Fox?
It was...
What was it?
Oh.
Damn.
I can't remember.
It was...
Um...
Uh...
Oh, wow!
Stop it!
It was, uh...
This thing?
Oh, what is...
This...
Oh...
What is...
It was a special place.
Um...
Something...
April 30th?
The soldier says to his captain, sir...
An escaping prisoner!
Oh, shoot.
Ouch!
No!
I died!
Okay, we're back here.
The question...
What?
I thought they were telling the joke.
They were, like, not telling the joke.
I'm not even looking this way.
How could they see me?
Sir, how do you need to request leave for this weekend?
You're a...
Why do you need it?
How do they even see me?
I'm gonna have a baby, sir.
Don't look at us.
Congratulations.
Request granted.
Next week, the captain asks him...
Private, was it a boy or a girl?
And the soldier replies...
Well, they're laughing, probably.
I don't know, sir.
Find out in nine months.
But also...
Hold on.
I wish there was, like, a way to know...
Because we're trying to find the encryption for the...
For the radio.
But also, we're trying to find a ladder.
Was it private?
These are the only...
I wish there was, like, a...
A goals thing, you know?
Like, under...
Inventory.
Oh, missions!
There it is!
Wait.
How do I get to that?
How do I...
How do I switch over?
Wait.
How do I switch to...
Uh...
X?
No.
Uh...
Q or E?
No.
Tab?
Oh!
Tab works.
Thank you.
Attach an encryption circuit to the radio.
Look for a rope and climb down into the sewers.
Okay.
Cool, cool, cool.
Um...
Praise the Lord!
Let's see.
I do wanna take them down.
Cause I...
Maybe in the boxes, you know?
Maybe I have to be really fast.
Hey, Mike.
Yeah.
Can you tell them again?
Tell them again?
Of course.
The Sarge says to the soldiers, Someone sent you a blank letter.
You can load the potty?
The soldier says...
I can?
You think so?
No.
It's...
I don't think so, though.
I don't think so.
No, I don't think that's how it works.
I think it's just one save.
It's from my wife, Sargeant.
How do you know that, soldier?
Oh, the coin.
That's right.
We have the coins.
Okay.
Select.
And...
Use.
Hey.
A coin.
You're not going to pick it up, right?
Yeah.
Why not?
Come on, Mike.
It's the oldest trick ever.
As soon as you crouch down, smack.
Smack.
What?
That ass.
The owner will show up and kick your ass.
What?
Sarge says to the...
It didn't work!
The soldier says, It's from my wife, Sargeant.
How do you know that, soldier?
Because we argued and we don't talk to each other.
Maybe if I run up to them while they're laughing.
Okay.
I'll try.
I need to request leave for this weekend.
Why do you need it, Private?
I'm going to have a baby, sir.
The second coin?
Congratulations.
Let's try the second coin.
Next week, the captain asks him...
Private, was it a boy or a girl?
And the soldier replies...
They didn't even care.
I don't know, sir.
I'll find out in nine months.
Okay.
Here we go.
And I got...
See?
I knew I had to go in here.
I got the rope.
I got the rope and everything.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Can I pick up my coins?
I can.
Okay.
This game owns.
And we got even more coins.
No wonder.
We got some sunglasses.
Protects the eyes from hard light.
Oh.
We're a cool guy wearing our sunglasses at night, you know?
Okay.
Well, we got a rope.
Perfect.
Wait.
People said you can combine stuff, right?
Yeah.
Combine my lighter.
Dang it.
Why can't I combine the lighter with the cigarettes?
Come on now.
But what if the elastic...
The lethal weapon you created with the patch was a slingshot?
No way.
Sort of childish, don't you think?
What were you gonna shoot?
I had a feeling because of the shape.
Pebbles?
Depleted uranium bars.
Three shots and goodbye guard.
Oh.
Okay.
Press space to shoot.
And we have 20 uranium.
That's why we've been picking up the balls.
Okay.
Mysterious.
Oh.
What's that?
Oh, yeah.
Now I remember.
Is it a boss?
It was that damn grenade guy.
Oh, no.
I wanted to punch the hell out of him.
But I couldn't reach him.
Why couldn't you reach him?
There was a ditch.
Oh.
A simple ditch stopped you.
Just jump.
This was no mere simple ditch.
Oh.
It was full of tentacles.
And blood-stained spears that moved up and down.
Oh.
And bony arms that tried to grab me.
What?
And deadly lays.
Okay.
Mr. Fox.
I get it.
You couldn't reach him.
For your own good, I'll let you go.
A lot include the spears, arms, and tentacles in my report.
Okay.
Now, Mr. Fox, please continue your story.
It is a boss fight.
All right.
The fight began as he tossed the first grenade at me.
Wow.
Grenade guy.
Oh, my gosh.
Running away.
Oh.
I'll be stupid, but not a coward.
No.
I'm hiding.
Oh, my gosh.
What are you talking about?
It's not...
Oh, my gosh.
There we go.
I can't tell what the...
Oh, shoot.
What, like, the...
Nice.
How...
The hitbox, you know?
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, yeah.
What are you...
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
I'm too slow.
Oh.
.
I searched the grenade guy.
I searched
the grenade guy.
Wait, wasn't there a ditch?
I used the bridge.
There was a bridge this whole time!
Oh my god.
You told me you couldn't cross the ditch.
Because I didn't see it at first.
I was completely focused on my opponent.
So true, so true.
He's just like me.
I see.
Nice.
Give me more uranium balls.
Give me this.
You're childish, don't you think?
What are these challenges?
He had a hook for a hand!
Nothing else.
Okay, cool.
Now we can head back.
Oh my gosh, everybody's still asleep.
We can go into the ditch.
I like this Mr. Fox guy.
What a goofball.
Nice.
Woah!
What the heck?
I just noticed his portrait.
Hello?
Are you in there?
Okay.
Let's combine the hook...
Oops.
Combine with...
that.
Rope with hook.
Perfect.
Before going down, I had to tend to some matters with Harris.
Oh.
Just kidding.
Um...
Fox is actually an 80-year-old man telling these fake war stories to his grandkids.
This is literally...
This is literally what Twin Snakes is.
Sorry.
I thought...
My desk started to move.
I think I accidentally hit it.
I was like, wait, is there an earthquake?
Um...
Yeah, the encrypted radio...
How do I get that?
...
Was there anything in here?
Uh-uh.
I didn't forget about the radio.
I just, uh...
feel like I've looked everywhere.
...
Punch the computers?
Oh, go back to the computer room.
Oh, so there was more in here.
Why didn't I think to punch the computers?
Oh gosh, I'm losing my...
Ah!
I had the circuit.
I just had to attach it to the radio.
I'm losing my touch.
Of course!
Why didn't I think to punch the computers?
Thank you guys.
Of course.
It only makes sense.
Combined with the radio.
With the modified radio, I could speak to Harris with no one listening.
Now, I just had to bring it to him.
This is real technology.
And the news later.
Why can't you just...
Use like the bed sheets or something, man.
Though they probably don't give bed sheets in prison, huh?
Here you are, Colonel.
A radio.
I've modified it to encrypt the signal.
Good job, son.
Do you have another one for you?
Not yet.
I'll call you through channel one as soon as I find another.
Good luck, son.
And Godspeed.
Thank you!
Obtain an encrypted radio.
We got a second chip, so...
Can I go down now?
I was about to go down that hole.
When?
When I remembered that I still hadn't radioed the Colonel.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta go find a...
A guard.
They wake up though, right?
Like, these guys have been down for a while.
Maybe I just search one.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, this guy.
Okay, we still have this guy.
Oh, single guard, I think.
I think this is the only guy still awake.
Like, actually.
I think he might be our only chance.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Aw, man.
But I got spotted.
I got spotted.
Hello?
Where's your radio?
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
What else you got?
Nothing?
Okay.
Oh,
I reached level...
I got...
I just got the achievement for reaching level 2.
That's so funny.
More uranium.
Okay, well...
Combine with this.
With the radio encrypted, I could talk to Harris.
Yippee!
I wouldn't have been able to escape without his help.
I hate to admit it, but the grumpy old man gave some good advice.
How do you know that, though?
Press W to use the radio.
Moshi moshi.
Oh, line 1.
Colonel, do you copy?
Copy.
I found a rope to go down the sewer.
And you're not down yet?
What the hell are you waiting for?
I'm on it, Colonel.
Turn off vocal effect.
Welcome back.
Thanks for 4 months.
Thank you.
Alright, now we go.
I couldn't see the bottom of that hole.
But I anchored the rope and I went down.
Okay.
Look for a rope.
Yes, that's what I did.
Yippee!
Wait, there was a secret.
Interesting.
There is a secret.
Huh?
Are there secrets in the chapters?
Something stinks really bad.
I anchored the rope and went down into the pitch darkness.
Finally I touched ground.
I missed 5 experiences.
because I got caught.
when I was attacking the guys.
But that's okay.
Good thing my nose is clogged.
You miss it?
Check the depth of the water.
I'm scared.
Wait, hold on.
I want to also see what happens if I call line 2 and 3.
Shit, there's no signal down here.
Wait, what about here?
Jesse here.
Over.
Shit, there's no signal down here.
Oh, wow!
Bad time to test it, I guess.
Synapse, thank you!
I got an arm!
There's no description!
It just says severed arm!
How do I check what the water...
How do I check the depth of the water?
Maybe with a coin?
Oh, whoops, sorry.
Oh, invisible wall!
Oh, use the arm!
I wanted to keep it!
Fine.
I dipped the severed arm in the water to calculate the depth.
Gosh.
As soon as I did, it started shaking.
When I pulled it back out, there was nothing but bones.
I couldn't explain what I saw, but my instincts told me this water might be dangerous.
I'm not gonna lie.
I had trouble getting where I needed to go.
In fact, I had to build a floating platform to get through.
Worse yet, everything down there was out for my blood.
What?
What else is down here?
I'm scared.
A popsicle!
Plastic drum.
Shut up.
Wait a second.
Thank you, thank you.
I considered floating the drums on the water and walking across, but they weren't very stable.
No, I can wear it!
I can wear it!
I can wear the drum!
Dang it.
Is your laundry done?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh!
There's fish people here.
Oh my god!
Hold on, Mr. Fox.
What exactly did you say attacked you?
What you just heard.
Some sort of hybrid between piranha and human.
A human piranha attacked you?
I see.
And in your opinion, could you elaborate how this hybrid could exist?
That question kept gnawing at the back of my brain the entire day.
What?
I dwelled on it over and over again.
Huh?
And after seeing everything I saw on that base, their facilities, their experiments, their labs, I reached the only logical explanation.
What?
What was that, Mr. Fox?
Yeah, what was it?
Mother.
Scientist?
That a woman hell-bent on becoming a mother was unable to afford standard artificial insemination.
So she sought illicit services on the black market instead.
And you know how the black market is.
They scam you with any fake shit.
Wait, what?
She took up an offer from a back alley doctor who did the operation as requested.
But she had yet to find out that she was actually fertilized with piranha sperm.
Jesus.
Poor woman.
Months passed and she became the mother of a school of human-piranha hybrids.
What this guy not- it's not the background guy just believing this.
And she became the mother of a school of human-piranha hybrids.
The horrified woman flushed them down the toilet.
They ended up in the sewers where they would keep reproducing, creating a colony of human-piranha hybrids.
The same ones that attacked me.
Oh my god.
That's- okay.
Guy doesn't even say anything about that.
He's just like, you know what?
That's okay.
We're just okay.
I'm afraid of when they pop up.
How do I know when they're gonna pop up, you know?
Good thing I invested in punch.
Jesse needs his pills again.
Oh, I have to roll.
Never mind, I didn't have to roll at all.
Why do I keep getting these plastic drums though?
Hello?
Lieutenant?
Uh, where's the phone?
Where's the phone?
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, it's me.
Sorry, guys.
There was no signal down in the sewers.
Sorry.
Not much progress.
I should still be near the prison.
Are you kidding me, Fox?
You're still too damn close.
You need to travel farther before coming topside.
I know, but there are sewer channels blocking my way.
Then build something to cross them.
Find some materials.
Okay, we got the materials.
Exactly.
I think I'm in the office of some sort of officer.
You should search for classified files about Operation Jericho.
Operation Jericho?
They're up to something.
I don't know what.
We must find out.
Hi.
Okay.
Yes.
Classified documents.
I have them.
Right here.
This button.
Whatever that is.
Oh, here, here, here, here.
That's classified.
Classi...
Oh!
Files.
I got the files.
Classified documentation about Operation Jericho.
Oh!
The first file was about an attack plan.
Its code name was Operation Jericho.
I couldn't find many details because it was encoded.
But anyone could understand a chart about casualties.
Its lines went all the way to the top.
Oh, my God.
The top.
Oh, yeah.
Let's also now call these.
Jessie here.
Over.
Oh.
Okay.
Jessie here.
Over.
No one.
No one responded.
Colonel, do you copy?
Copy.
I found some documents.
Yeah.
Operation Jericho.
Looks like it talks about an attack plan.
Combine it with the lighter?
I have no idea.
It's encoded.
I'll keep searching for more documents, Colonel.
Operation Jericho is a rumor only known by a few officers and, of course, the enemy.
The enemy.
How did you find out about it, Mr. Fox?
Through the documents, you dummy.
As I told you, Colonel Harris, I'm the only one who knows.
Colonel Harris asked me to search for files about it.
Yes.
The deceased Colonel Harris?
Yes!
I have the feeling that this officer didn't believe anything I was saying.
We have a girlfriend?
It's understandable.
I don't believe you either.
Oh, really?
Wait, what?
Well, Miss Incredulous, why ask me to tell you the story?
Well, I like the way you tell it.
And since there are no theaters here.
Great.
What?
So, what was Operation Jericho?
We're telling a story within a story within a story.
The location is actually a clandestine base with a company codenamed X Army, commanded by someone named General X.
General X.
They were planning a large-scale attack against Allied posts.
X is going to give it to you.
And that plan was?
Be patient.
That comes later.
Hey!
Don't be like that.
Come on, tell me.
The officer that was taking my statement...
What?
...was also curious about what I knew.
What is happening?
And what exactly do you know about Operation Jericho, Mr. Fox?
I don't know.
That it was a hell of an operation.
Harris and I knew the details thanks to the files we found.
Correction.
I found.
Again, how much did you exactly find out?
Let me continue.
You'll find out later.
Yeah, we're telling a story.
You can't get all the information up front, mister.
Come on.
Gosh.
Let me do a little world building and such.
Right?
Come on.
This person's going to come in and be like, who ransacked my room?
I don't know.
Oh.
If I go back down here...
Hold on.
Let's go back up because it says I can leave.
Let's see if I leave.
Oh, I need a...
Card key one.
Okay.
All right.
Time to combine our three drums.
How many layers of framing device are we on?
I don't know.
Combine.
Oh, wait.
With the toilet paper.
Okay.
Dang it.
Can I combine the...
It won't let you combine the lighter with the...
That's so messed up.
Dang it.
Okay.
Said I would try to find more, but like...
Yeah, we need to go down that way.
Hmm.
Okay.
Is there anything in here that I can use to open anything in here?
The lighter.
Okay.
I'm going to use it on this.
Nope.
What is that red button-looking thing?
I want to press it.
You missed a path up above in the sewers?
I did?
Did I?
Oh, it's a stamp.
Oh, it looks like a red button.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
No, I don't think I missed anything, because...
Oh!
This way.
Okay.
Just kidding.
You're right.
Oh!
In the inventory, press any key over an item to bind a shortcut.
Huh?
Press it later in the game to select the item directly.
What?
Press a key?
What's any key?
What?
Hmm?
We got another barrel.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
I'm eavesdropping.
Roscoe!
Escaped?
How?
Through the sewers?
Shit!
No.
Don't send anyone.
If he hides like a rat, he'll die like a rat.
Switch on the shredder.
The shredder?
Yeah.
Wait.
Why are there shredders in the...
In the sewers?
I did see that on the right side.
General Roscoe.
I want to see if he does anything else.
I wonder...
Oh.
Maybe I can...
Hey.
You hear this?
Oh.
I actually...
Oh, okay.
I was going to say.
I don't think it...
There's a dev in the...
Oh!
Shredders.
Oh.
That asshole Roscoe.
Dev in the chat.
Hello.
Thank you.
Later he'll be a pain in my ass.
But they'd end up saving it too.
Why?
So we can hide in here from the shredders.
I'm assuming.
But I can also just kind of go through here.
Look at that.
I can just kind of...
What if I throw a coin?
What if I throw a coin, you guys?
Oh no.
My coin.
I wasted my coin.
Oh my coin.
Wait.
You guys.
I wasted my coin.
I missed your pick up.
Pick up the coin.
No.
I'm right here.
Oh.
Look what the cat dragged in.
He escaped prison.
It's me.
Got some big balls coming here, rodent.
Rodent.
The situation was foobar.
He was armed and hunkered down behind his desk.
I was screwed.
I have.
So what did you do?
In five nanoseconds, I scrutinized the room and noticed a very subtle detail.
What's that?
There is a large globe in the middle of the room.
There is?
Oh yes, there is.
I already had what I needed to take him down.
Oh.
What do you mean?
I hate to be a wanted trigger.
Huh.
Oh my God.
I do?
Ralsei.
No!
Ow.
Oh my God.
No!
Ouch.
Um.
Dang it.
Good job.
Good try, everybody.
Why don't I just shoot him?
Why can't I just shoot the guy with my slingshot?
Maybe I should...
I'm not bleeding, that's the issue.
I don't want to use it, but it recovers health.
Is this worldwide Minto?
Oh, because the desk is the barrier.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Let's see.
Joined a stream to a death.
Yeah, you know, I'm always delivering the best kind of content, right?
You have infinite use of bandage for bleeding.
Yeah, but it doesn't heal you.
You know what?
I'm just going to use it.
It says it heals me over time.
That's so nice.
Okay, awesome, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Long the chili?
Oh, chibi!
Chili model!
Okay, let's try this again, you guys.
At least I get to keep my koi this time.
Well, I guess I can skip this part.
Okay!
Nice!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh gosh!
Wait, how do I heal?
Wait!
Oh gosh, I'm going to die.
You're pissing me off!
Damn you!
And someone walks into the room and just sees two guys down on the floor.
Okay, third time's the charm, everybody.
Third time's the charm.
In fact, if I get hit, I probably should just use this, huh?
They give you a free one anyway, so...
Okay.
Use the god mode.
Oh, wait.
It says I sacrifice a ring.
I don't have a ring.
Also, I can do this.
I don't need a god mode for this.
Huh.
Did I just hear a rat?
A rat.
That was close.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, this is a really bad angle to be at.
I can't get it.
Wait, I can't get him.
From this angle.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah, you're pissing me off!
Nice shot.
Okay.
Yippee!
Sucker!
What's the game called?
Oh my gosh.
The one with the cars.
What's it called?
We got...
Oh, the card key!
Nice.
And we didn't even need to use that.
Rocket League!
Guys, I have such sick brain.
This is fun.
Worldwide Minto!
Now we can leave.
Wait, how does he get out of this room?
Oh, I just noticed that one too.
Good thing we didn't leave.
How does he get out of here?
He must have a secret door.
Through the sewers.
Duh.
The wood!
Why are you sending 50 Gufted?
What the heck?
Thank you!
Why?
Thank
you, but why?
Why not?
I don't know.
As I proceeded down the sewer sidewalk, I noticed a path nearby I couldn't reach.
Why not?
It was across the sewer water.
Just jump.
What was the distance to the other side?
The wood!
Thank you for another Friptor!
Oh my gosh.
One yard or ten yards?
Thank you!
Spawn of the...
Thanks for four months as well.
Thank you!
Should we do one yard or ten yards?
You want to see the ten yards?
Okay.
Around ten yards.
Hold on.
Weren't those channels narrow?
You're contradicting yourself, Mr. Fox.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
That's because the sewer fumes were psychotropic and messing with my senses.
What?
I see.
I realized I needed something to cross to the other side.
Does that mean there were no fish people?
There were no fish people then?
Because it was psychotropic?
Can I use this?
Select.
Use.
I considered floating the drums on the water and walking across, but they weren't very stable.
Ah.
Okay.
But we have our key card now.
So we can go in here.
And we can go downstairs.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
It's been 50 years.
We emptied the potty.
We finally did it.
Real soldiers never look at their reflection.
Let's see.
What's over here?
Oh.
Heading east, I ran into a hound.
No.
A puppy.
You didn't hurt it, did you?
A puppy?
That monster was the size of a horse.
Why are we suddenly a...
Even so, I wanted to see if it was friendly.
Puppy.
Are you a good boy?
Boy?
But that hound was trained to kill.
He's got red eyes.
Its bloody eyes looked at me like I was a little boy.
Puppy.
Okay.
I don't think we can attack the dog.
Our girlfriend will break up with us.
And that would be really unfortunate.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Who's there?
Not me.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Damn, cat.
What if I...
Who's there?
There's a cat.
T-Rex?
Mike.
They might believe me if I say I'm Mike.
I'm Mike.
Everybody's Mike.
What if I say cat?
It might go...
Meow.
What if I say T-Rex?
I think I'll scare him.
T-Rex.
That is pretty good.
Damn T-Rexes.
Hold on.
Weren't they extinct?
Ah!
Oh no.
Shoot it.
Oh shoot.
Guys, I think I'm gonna die here.
I think I'm gonna die here.
Now what if I do the cat?
I think I might...
Who's there?
I thought he would get scared of the T-Rex.
He'd be like whoa scary.
Scary!
Cat...
Don't send backup!
Gosh,
I do have to be Mike, don't I?
Okay, let's just...
Let's just be Mike.
Why didn't you meow?
You dummy!
Gosh!
What's this guy's name?
Fox.
What are you doing?
I'm Mike.
I'm just a Mike.
I'm Mike!
Phew.
Nice.
Just a Mike, you guys.
Just a...
Just a Mike.
Just a Mike, everybody.
Oh.
Good night.
I got another handkerchief.
We get a lot of those, don't we?
Get a lot of handkerchiefs.
Hmm.
What kind of...
How do you find secrets, I wonder?
Like, what do you have to look for?
Like, are there secrets in the walls?
Are the walls...
Do the walls have secrets?
Is he convulsing?
No!
I was just stepping on him, you know?
What if I, like, roll into this, you know?
No?
Hmm.
Heading south, I ran into a couple of trucks.
That was my big chance to escape.
Oh, yeah.
We can just hide in the back.
First, I had to get rid of the guards.
I did?
Why can't I just hide in the back of it?
Just hide in the back of the truck.
Let's get...
Oh, shoot.
You didn't see...
Okay.
This game feels like if you get an alert...
Feels a little less like...
Able to get out of the alerts...
Phase.
I might just be wrong.
I might be wrong about that, you know?
Obviously, but...
The barrel's cracked?
Which one?
Oh, I see it.
This one.
Nope.
It's just a...
Just a...
Design.
Maybe it's oil, you know?
Why are you guys ganged up?
Oh, my gosh.
Pick him up and take him...
Here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
How do I get this guy?
I'm gonna be in the light.
Hmm.
Never mind.
Haha.
I'm too good.
I'm too good at this game.
Oh!
We got a ring!
Remember I said sacrifice a ring?
To get the...
Invincibility?
All right.
I'm...
I'm examining the engines.
I'm examining...
Oh, there we go.
I took a glance and my worst fears came true.
It was an old diesel engine with no AdBlue or particulate filter.
What does that mean?
Running away in that truck would have polluted the area with nitrogen oxides and micro...
Micro particles.
And I wasn't willing to sacrifice the environment for a hasty retreat.
Oh, my gosh.
He's so considerate.
So I armed myself with patience and I kept searching for another way to escape.
Wow, Jesse.
I didn't know you were so eco-friendly.
Jesse Fox.
Well, it's nothing really.
Wow.
You know...
With the name Fox, he just cares about the environment so much.
Captain Planet over here.
See, this looks like suspicious.
Like a wall that I could be able to break.
Or here.
Or nowhere.
Oh.
That was loud.
Let's see.
We're gonna go inside.
Dev says punch the side of the truck horn.
Really?
Where's the dev?
Sorry, I haven't seen you.
Thank you, though.
Die, truck.
Yeah!
Yeah, die, truck.
Punch the tank.
Oh, gosh.
This guy's right here.
Is he gonna come back?
Die, truck.
Oh!
Oh, shoot.
Nope.
We're fine.
Oh, nothing.
Mike!
All good.
Oh!
We leveled up!
Yippee!
Rapid recovery.
Your HP is recovered twice as fast.
Apply bandages and first aid kits twice as fast!
Oh, wait.
What do you mean your HP is recovered?
I feel like the kits is really good, though.
Probably.
You get health back faster.
Oh!
Yes!
Okay.
I think healing would be better.
I think having...
Because it's kind of, you know...
Having to stop for so long to put on the bandage.
And it's bandage and first aid kit.
So I'm gonna go with this one.
Nice.
You guys good?
You guys...
Oh, sorry.
You have nothing else to give me?
Nothing?
I'm trying to pick you up.
Oh!
You did have more.
You were holding out on me.
Okay.
I'm trying to pick him up.
I'm so bad at picking these guys up.
Okay, whatever.
They're fine down there.
They're fine.
They're cozy.
The dev is Jack Lefevre.
Oh, thank you!
I'm hot and you're hot!
You're hot and you're hot!
Yes!
Oh!
I'm hot and you're hot!
You're hot and you're hot!
Cool.
Thank you guys.
You guys made my day.
Bye -bye.
Bye-bye.
I'm ready to go home.
Nothing is safe, I'm just saying.
Is Otacon in here?
Nope.
No nerds in the closet.
And no sexy ladies either.
That doesn't sound very eco-friendly.
I'm going against everything that Jesse Fox stands for.
Sorry, Jesse Fox.
I love arson.
What is that thing?
Let's see.
So, let's see...
Flammable.
Keep away from heat.
And then some raw...
Oh, the dog!
The dog looked at me like I was raw meat.
What if I just give him some raw meat, baby?
It wasn't over here, was he?
No.
Is there a map?
I haven't tried.
Let me try M.
No.
Let's give the dog the meat.
Jesse...
Mr. Fox, I'm still waiting on an explanation for the noose.
Later, officer.
Oh my gosh, there's more important pressing matters here, officer, please.
But before we do that...
I think it saved, but...
Just in case.
There we go.
What happens if you combine the gasoline and the lighter?
I mean...
I just saved.
What a...
Oops.
What better time than to combine the two...
Yes.
Cool.
Good thing you saved.
Who would have guessed that that would have happened?
That's craziness.
Here, doggie, doggie.
Heading east, I ran into a hound.
A hound?
A puppy.
Oh, wait, we saw this part.
Hold on, I'm just gonna skip it.
Eat the meat.
It needs unlimited raw meat.
Okay, it needs meat.
Okay, quick, okay.
Eat the meat.
Eat the meat!
Eat the meat, eat the meat, eat the...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my...
I'm punching the tank.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
These chewing sounds.
Okay, we're good.
What's that...
What's that blue thing in that?
Oh.
Watch out.
There's a guard looking here.
If you move, he'll see you.
Tell me when he's not looking.
That bastard won't move.
He's over here all the time.
Fuck.
Hold on.
I have an idea.
What's the idea?
Yo, Mike!
Mike!
Shut up.
I got pictures of your mom moving the bathtub.
Want to buy them?
Real cheap.
What?
You bastard!
I'm done with his shit.
Just go shoot that bastard.
No!
We have to save him!
No, no, no!
Nice.
Thanks for the help.
Thank you for knocking out that dick.
By the way, name's Jesse Fox.
Jesse Fox.
I'm Mike.
Hold on.
Don't tell me the prisoner was also named Mike.
No.
Hold on.
It wasn't Mike.
I'm Robert.
Oh, Robert.
Let's see if I can get you out of here.
Everybody is Mike.
Thanks Fox, but no.
If you escape, they'll shoot you.
I'd rather be jailed than buried.
Oh my gosh.
You don't have a radio, do you?
I do.
Hold on.
I'll get one for you.
Oh, now we have a friend!
You don't have one?
Okay.
We gotta get a radio for our new Robert friend.
Oh shoot!
Oh my god.
That scared the heck out of me.
Oh!
Oh gosh!
Ah!
I'm such an idiot!
Oh no!
That's not what I meant to do!
Oh, there we go.
I'm bleeding out, you know?
Um, anyways.
You got anything else?
I did a whoopsy!
You guys, I did a bit of a whoopsy.
Oh, uh, here's your radio.
Oh, do I have to encrypt it?
Yeah.
We gotta go get more computer parts.
Hold on.
One second, Robert.
Mikey, Mikey, Mikey.
Mm-hmm.
Nice suit.
We need stronger arms.
We need to become big buff.
Nice suit!
Oh.
Okay.
Wow.
Get...
Oh.
Okay.
We can only hold six at a time.
So let's use that up real quickly.
Big, meaty claws.
Oh, a wooden platform.
Okay.
Tomorrow's tweet.
Good morning, Michael.
Yeah.
Everybody's Mikey now.
Oh.
There's a little bit of blood here.
It's my fault, honestly.
Okay.
Oops.
Hey, Robert.
Robert.
Did you get that radio?
Yeah.
Here you go.
Thanks, Fox.
I'll call you if I find out anything.
I'll be 78 years old, walking in my chair, and I don't know where I'll remember when mint football knocked me out.
Don't remember.
Yippee!
Now, what?
What?
Oh, I haven't called the guy in a while.
Do you read me?
Loud and clear, Fox.
I have a wooden platform.
I have a platform?
So what are you waiting for?
Get back to the sewers and keep running.
Oh.
I'm not so sure it'll hold my weight.
Be creative, son.
Look for floats of some kind.
Stop punching me.
Mike.
Jesse here.
Do you copy?
I hear you.
Oh.
Hey, Robert.
You don't look like a military man.
Robert.
Of course not.
I'm a photographer.
Oh, my gosh.
He's looking for the pretzel.
You're not a paparazzi, are you?
That's right.
A paparazzi.
Paparazzi.
You're the worst kind, too.
Who was your favorite lady to stalk?
Her name was Big Bertha.
Big Bertha.
Oh, Big.
That your thing?
It was the name of a German howitzer.
I'm actually a war journalist.
You thought you said you were a paparazzi.
Yep.
I said I was the worst fucking kind, too.
Big.
Hey, Robert.
You must have fucked up royally to end up locked in here.
Big Bertha.
I've seen things I wasn't meant to fuck.
I don't think they're supposed to lock up the journalists.
Jesse here.
Over.
Anybody going to answer my call?
Okay.
No one's going to pick up for Jesse?
Oh, I thought that was a person.
I'm kind of blocking it, but it looks a little bit like a person.
Like a lady statue or something.
Hmm.
This is an interesting area.
What could this be?
Oh.
Nothing interesting.
What?
You didn't even look in there.
What the?
Jesse.
Jesse Fox.
Nothing useful.
Look one more time.
Nothing interesting.
Okay.
I guess we'll come back here.
Let's all remember the very uninteresting...
red crate.
Can you punch the fire extinguisher?
No, I tried earlier.
I actually did.
Okay.
Time to get back to the sewers.
That was quite some ways to go.
Oh, shoot.
I need the meat.
Okay.
Meat!
Is my dog getting fat?
Oh, my God.
He's so fat now.
Oh, he can barely even chase us.
Oh, my God.
We overfed the dog.
Oh, my gosh.
How terrible of us.
We overfed the dog.
Okay.
Let's combine this...
and our barrels...
and we got a little floaty.
After making the platform, I had what I needed to cross the sewer channels to freedom.
Some kind of Tom and Jerry nonsense.
What if we go back?
I don't think he...
You know...
He wasn't like that until we left the screen, you know?
The sound effects of him running too.
Bark and grow fat.
You're just a waddling dog.
Keep waiting, buddy.
That reminds me of something.
The sound reminds me of something and I can't remember what.
Okay.
We'll leave him alone now.
No, not Mr. Krabs.
Something else from like another video game.
Okay.
I was so hungry that I almost bit into the raw steak.
Oops.
But I remembered that it's a crime to kill an animal for its meat.
What?
Are you vegetarian?
No.
Killing them is a crime.
That's why I eat them when they're still alive.
Jesse Fox!
What is wrong with you?
You guys, if you're ever just like, why can't I get a girlfriend?
Remember, Jesse Fox got a girlfriend and he eats animals alive.
So, you know...
This guy is...
Oh, my gosh.
I actually just pressed that on accident.
That's so funny.
Gosh.
I can't with this game.
Okay.
Let's select this and then use this and then...
Oh.
Hold on, Mr. Fox.
The platform just vanished.
What?
Of course not.
I picked it up every time I got to the other side.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
You didn't mention that.
Sounded like it vanished.
Oh.
Well, I didn't feel like I had to mention something so obvious.
Then should I write down that you picked up the platform every time you used it?
Yes, of course.
Well, Mr. Fox...
Naked Snake eats them alive too.
Please continue with your story.
And Naked Snake, everybody is in love with the legend.
I'm just saying.
Maybe...
Maybe we're all missing something, you know?
Maybe there's more to this than I am...
than I thought, you know?
An empty bottle.
Okay.
How do I get past this thing?
Wait, there's like no wall.
If I put the platform down...
Oh.
Okay, I think I have to put the platform down.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Thank you.
So all we need to do is start...
To find love is start eating animals alive.
Thanks for the advice, Minto.
Yeah!
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
I think I didn't put it down.
There we go.
Like that far?
You know?
Okay, that's good.
Oh!
Shredded tuna.
Mr.
Fox, the noose.
Oh my gosh.
Get over it.
Don't try my patience, Mr. Fox.
I want that medal.
I'm gonna get it.
Something stinks really bad.
Oh, another empty bottle.
Wait a second.
We've been getting these handkerchiefs?
Ew, damp with mucus.
We've been getting...
It's just like me.
I wonder if we can make like a molotov.
Ah, yeah, yeah.
Someone in the chat.
You had the same idea as me.
No!
I punched instead of a...
Oh, dang it.
You jerks.
I hope this guy gets shredded.
Oh.
Okay, have the platform right here.
Ready?
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Mr. Fox, the noose.
Excuse me.
Later.
Skip, skip, skip dialogue.
That was so close, you guys.
That was so close.
Which way do we wanna go first?
Let's go this way.
Potty.
Nice.
Wait, I need to level what?
Question mark.
Okay, interesting.
When you die that close to a save.
I know, right?
So true.
How far?
Okay.
It throws me off too because it kind of doesn't put the thing right where I put it.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes it's a little off.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, God.
Good golly golly.
Oh golly.
What is that?
Okay, we're safe here.
You can't take me.
Drink the water.
Go.
This one goes all the way down.
Oh my goodness!
You coward!
You coward fish, you!
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Wait,
I'm on the water.
I think that that would be an issue.
But I guess not.
Yeah, we're gaming, you guys.
We're gaming.
Come here!
He did get taken out by it!
Let's go.
Gaming real?
Slow and steady?
I feel like after this I should save.
Why can't I just, you know... I should save?
But like, also...
Why can't I just, um...
Like...
Why can't I just release it into the sewers?
Who cares, right?
Friends get ready.
Uh-oh.
I'm scared.
What do you mean?
Why are we getting ready?
By the way, how many rats were down there?
Oh!
Pfft.
No rats.
There were like no rats.
A lot of rats?
Like a party of rats?
Like a whole...
Like...
It's like a quinceaera of rats.
Amount of rats.
Hell yeah.
The sewer wasn't full.
It was a festival of sass and rats.
Sass and...
Ass, ass and rats.
They were everywhere.
Rushing to devour me alive.
It was horrible.
It felt like I was a huge chunk of cheese.
Me, I'm the cheese!
Oh my god.
I think I went the wrong way, you guys.
Ow!
No, I'm cheese!
I'm cheese!
I don't wanna be cheese to me too!
Oh my god.
Oh!
What is this?
Go punch master!
Jessie!
Oh my god.
I'm just cheese.
Why was my cheese self so much slower than my normal self?
Oh!
Wait, have we been here before?
No.
This one, I don't think...
Yeah, we can't even get past this, so we're kind of trapped now.
Inside some debris, I found an old flamethrower.
What?
A flamethrower?
It was in bad condition, but I could fix it.
The worst part was the fuel tank was savagely chewed apart.
It couldn't be saved, so I set out to replace it.
Broken?
Broken old flamethrower.
Let's go!
The fury?
Stop.
Would make sense why it's down here.
Brutally attacking a fish man?
It's like you're already a member of FaZe Connect.
No, no.
I think I need stronger punches.
Alright, let's go to this ladder.
Oooh!
Now we're right in front of a... bathroom!
Jessie's voice actor says, good job.
Thanks!
Stop you guys, I already have a big head.
I'm taking up so much of the screen.
Good thing, it's nice that they gave you so much health after the rats.
Do items disappear after a while?
Let's go down instead of up first.
Let's go down here.
Just kidding!
Oh, just kidding!
Wait, then where do I go?
The whole dev team is watching, no pressure.
No, if everybody's watching, I'm having so much fun.
Thank you!
This is so awesome.
We're all here, stop!
Oh my gosh, no pressure.
Let's see, what was back here?
Was there anything else we could...
Do I molotov something?
Maybe I blow up the tires.
Ask the radio?
Oh my gosh, you guys are so right.
What if I was lost in Metal Gear?
Of course I would ask Colonel.
Shit, there's no signal down here.
You guys, there's no signal!
Oh wait.
Jessie here, over.
Shit, there's no signal down here.
What do you mean down here?
Jessie, we're up on land!
Here, maybe in the bathroom.
Something, something.
Boss makes a dollar, I make a dime.
That's why I call Colonel on company time.
Jessie here, over.
Shit, there's no signal down here.
This place sucks!
Can't even check my memes while I'm on the toilet.
We're on our own, you guys.
That's why I watch VTubers.
On company time.
Let's see.
Combine with you.
And combine...
you...
Combine you...
with you.
Oh, it doesn't work.
Just kidding.
Wait, I can make another one even.
Combine you with you.
Oh wait, the gas tank is broken!
Oh!
I had to replace the flamethrower's broken fuel tank before I could fill it up.
Oh, the fuel tank.
Gas tank, fuel tank, same thing, right?
Can't wait for unmetal unvengeance.
Oh, the big blue one.
You think the plastic drum would work?
Oh!
And it's gas, gas, gas, baby!
After the repairs, my flamethrower was ready.
The tubes were covered in rust, so I took great care to avoid overheating it.
Okay, no overheating.
Got it, got it.
How do I use the flamethrower?
Z.
Oh?
Z?
X.
Hmm?
Huh?
Oh, space!
Did it say that?
Why does it say Z then?
Whoa!
Okay, no, okay.
Got it, got it, got it.
Yeah!
Okay!
Oh, no!
Oh my gosh, this is not good.
Can I punch the rats?
No, I can't punch the rats.
I died to the rats!
Oh, rats.
Okay, but we know what to do now.
Combine.
Gas it up, baby.
Select, baby.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
I'm not gonna overheat it.
Hopefully.
We're just gonna take this baby out.
We're not even gonna focus on the... the tire yet.
We're gonna focus on the rats.
Here they come.
Yeah, yeah.
So easy.
Oh, good.
Oh, there's more of them!
See?
So easy.
Yeah, I thought the rats were gonna keep coming and keep on coming, you know?
I thought they were gonna be infinite rats.
Okay.
No more rats, maybe.
I say as I creep...
Oh, gosh.
Just run!
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's more rats.
The music is so...
The music gets me so bad.
It's like...
It's making me panic a little bit.
Okay, let's wait before we continue onwards.
Jump scared endlessly by the rat brigade.
At least I'm not a piece of cheese this time.
Where are the rats gonna come from?
Okay, now they want us to circle the rats.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
I'm gonna die to rats!
Oh, I'm gonna die to rats.
I'm gonna die to the rats!
Oh, I'm stuck on the wall.
No!
They keep coming!
Okay, now we're actually dead to the rats.
No!
Okay, once we get through the first two rats, you guys, we gotta save.
I need a plan for that one.
We need a plan for that one.
Let's see.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good, good, good.
And...
Select.
Okay.
Typing of the rats.
You can use your porta-potty more than once.
I just emptied it, so we're good.
NYC Subway experience.
Rat Eater.
This is like the-the crab fight, or whatever, you know.
Oh, wow.
Take care of these guys first.
Okay, now second round of rats.
Come out!
Okay, you rats!
Perfect.
So as we pray, unlimited rat works.
This is because I chose earlier about the rats, man.
Oh gosh!
I'm not bleeding, am I?
I don't think so.
I think I'm only bleeding out if it's like right around the screen, right?
I like how... actually it's kind of subtle, but when I use the flamethrower, it lights up the room.
Did you guys notice that?
It's a cool little subtle detail.
Okay.
Now, let's port-a-potty.
Yeah, it's a nice little attention to detail, right?
Can we use the meat?
Can we throw the meat if you like?
Oh.
I don't know.
This is a vermintide.
Okay.
Alright.
They came out from... where first?
Above, I think?
Oh, I didn't combine these either.
Nice.
Okay.
Would you fight one legendary soldier or 100 rats?
Oh
my god, they come from above too!
Oh my gosh, they come from everywhere!
What the...
Oh, my thing blew up.
I overheated it.
They come from above!
They don't just come from the holes either!
They come from everything!
Oh, boy...
Oh my gosh.
I was trying to see if I could quarter them.
But if they come...
If they come where I'm standing too, it doesn't really help.
Huh?
I know that...
It seems like I need to circle them somehow.
Like, loop them.
I think you need to keep moving.
Yeah.
You were really on fire there.
What's the AI summary saying?
Oh, gosh.
Ah!
Oh!
Am I going little bits?
Yippee!
Ah!
Reign of rodents!
I wanna use the bathroom, please!
Oh, I see it down there.
Oh, gosh.
Wait!
Can I use the bathroom again?
It needs to be emptied.
What if I just try it again?
I couldn't use that potty.
It was full.
I had to empty it in some toilet.
No!
Why didn't you just empty it anywhere?
Yeah!
Because I'm not a pig.
We're in the silvers!
Moreover, if I wanted to water the plants anywhere, why did I need a potty?
And you took your urine with you?
Yes, until the next toilet.
There, I emptied it to reuse it again.
Wait, why don't I just go back?
What's stopping me from going back?
You know what?
Never mind.
Maybe I'm a genius.
Hold on.
What if I just go back to the bathroom?
What if I just...
What if I just run all the way back home?
What if I just go back?
What if I just take the stairs, the little ladder, and dump it and re-save?
Oh, some rats are gonna stop me?
Huh?
What if I just...
Yes, tensai, tensai.
My mom made a joke on how you kept dying.
Stop, mom!
Mom, don't embarrass me!
There we go!
See you!
Why does Jesse have such strange morals?
He's just like, I can't just...
You know what?
I kind of get it, though.
Even though this is the sewers and it's disgusting and smelly and nasty, even I don't think I would feel right.
Even I would feel like I...
It needs to go into a toilet so it gets cleaned in a proper channel.
Rat assassins are terrifying, but they got nothing on Zanzibar land.
Poisonous hamsters.
Oh yeah, I remember those.
Oh yeah.
I remember when Big Boss said, the hamster is unleashed.
And just released all these hamsters.
Okay.
Now we saved right here, so when we inevitably die, we can just start back where we started.
Oh gosh.
It's quartering me!
Oh my goodness.
We made it, you guys.
Somehow.
Oh man.
Wait, are we gonna have to deal with rats and...
And spikes?
Thank you, thank you.
Bye.
Minto cute.
Dough.
Stop it.
Let's see.
Let's get our floating contraption back.
And have C on the ready.
There's a secret on this screen?
Is it here?
Secret on this screen.
Secret?
Oh, you know what?
I'll take that.
Take that.
Secret?
Secret.
Do I need to burn something?
Maybe in this hole.
Nope.
Small chest in the upper middle left?
What?
There's a chest?
A weird box in the upper right?
That's not a chest.
That's water, is it not?
What's happening?
Oh, this one's fast.
Secret on this screen.
Maybe...
Hold on.
Maybe it's somewhere like along the walls that...
Like here?
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think I know.
I think I put my floaty there.
The hell you did...
Okay.
Mystery.
Stamina?
Oh, it's a passive.
Woo hoo!
Why is it so creepy in here?
It's so creepy in here.
Oh, ah.
Okay, good.
Oh, shush.
That was close.
Thank you, Dev!
I'll take it.
It's okay, all we gotta do is take out some rats again.
Awww...
Okay.
No worries, everybody!
No problems!
No problems, we can get back in our spot.
Easy peasy.
Right where we left off.
Right here.
Easy peasy.
Very cute.
This is the first time I sent this.
No, it's not.
Don't lie to me!
Sometimes the placement for this really...
Oh yeah, that's right.
We gotta heal.
Really?
Gets me bad.
Alright, let's not get greedy with this one now.
Huh.
Oh, why did it just save?
Run!
Punch the wall, punch the wall.
You must have been very lonely down there.
Oh.
Nah, I had some company.
The rats?
What is that?
The sewer junk?
Do I flamethrow you?
Oh, okay.
What's he gonna do?
Bold as a...
Aaaaah!
More rats!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I can't get that yet.
More
rats?
More of them.
I gotta get him too, though.
Okay.
Alright, more rats.
And that thing had tentacles?
What?
Well, now that you mention it...
I don't like that we're rewriting history here.
Um, why is...
He's just trying to make himself seem cooler, huh?
Six tentacles?
Are you guys...
You guys are so mean to me.
It had six tentacles.
Aaaaah!
And rats.
Oh, okay.
Speak of the...
Pearl-p discomfort Rodents.
Speaking of the...
Oh my gosh.
AAAAAH!!!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
You guys, you guys...
This isn't good.
THIS ISN'T GOOD!
You guys, this isn't good.
This is actually quite bad.
Oh my god.
I can't even get a hit in.
I couldn't even get a hit in.
It feels like Resident Evil.
You must have been very lonely down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's get as many hits as we can.
Oh, uh oh.
I also need to...
I'll not overheat my thing.
Kill the rat.
And that thing had tentacles?
What if I said only two tentacles?
Okay, we'll say four.
Let's go in the middle.
Four is a spooky number, you guys.
I think four is a good medium.
Four tentacles.
Spooky number, right?
Four is a spooky number.
Four means death.
I know.
It had four pairs of tentacles.
No!
All I was trying was just a spooky number.
This is NOT fair!
This IS not fair.
Not fair!
Need
to avoid the-
Wait...
well, the rats not come upstairs?
Can I actually hide here?
Not hide, but you know what I mean.
Oh, never mind.
NO!
They definitely come up here.
Seems like a decent spot, though.
Right?
Gosh, never mind.
How am I supposed to get any hits in?
Wait.
Select and use... there we go.
Can you come back here, mister?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck!
I
wonder what happens if we pick two, then.
Two giant tentacles?
Two... dozen?
What if it says two dozen tentacles?
Do you think that'll happen?
Sewer junk.
How long have I been streaming for?
Oh, only two and a half hours.
And here come the rats.
I scheduled the rats.
The rats on schedule.
The rats are on schedule.
Two million tentacles.
Too many tentacles.
And that thing had tentacles?
Let's try two.
I'm so curious.
I think it's gonna say, like, two dozen tentacles.
It had two dozen tentacles.
You guys, I'm a Metal Gear fan.
I know this.
I'm a Metal Gear fan.
That's how you know I'm a real one, you know?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
There was no running.
Wait a second.
Can I use my little thing?
Oh, I can.
Are there...
No, I was gonna say, are there less rats?
Nope.
Oh my gosh.
No.
I'm trapped.
I can't even...
I can't...
I can't even get a hint in on the guy.
He's taking out the thing!
He's taking out the platforms!
Wait, this is actually good.
Oh, never mind.
I didn't notice my health.
But the platforms are good because that means we only have to deal with one set of rats.
You must have been very lonely down there.
Meh.
I had some company.
What does six do?
It gives him six tentacles.
Oh!
I'm hacking?
I'm...
Yeah, maybe he'll take out the platforms faster if he has more tentacles, you know?
Yeah.
And that thing had...
So maybe the two dozen is better than...
than...
Not.
No.
It had two dozen tentacles.
Uh-uh.
Look, there's only a few rats, even.
Just kidding.
There's a ton of rats.
I was like, wow, it only sent out a few.
So few rats.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, we're trapping ourselves?
We're trapping ourselves?
Here we go.
We can reach him from there though.
Let's select this just for now, so I can have it on...
Okay, run, run!
No!
I missed my chance!
Okay, we got him a couple bit.
Yowza!
A yowza!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
That was close, that was close.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice suit.
If I can get some hits in, it stops the attack even.
Well, not entirely, I suppose.
Just a little bit.
But we can get some attacks in.
Zumpets.
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Nice, nice.
Maybe we can get another hit.
I nearly had that thing dead, but then my luck turned south.
Wait, what do you mean?
The old flamethrower.
Broke apart.
Broke apart as I continued the fight.
No!
So I finished it the old-fashioned way.
With my fists!
Oh, okay.
How am I supposed to punch him?
From this angle, from this distance?
Where is... show back up.
Ouch!
Oh, ouch!
Oh!
Oh, he trapped me!
That was so unfair!
No!
Oh, he trapped me!
I should have punched him while I was sitting there.
But, this is the strat.
The 24 tentacles works.
He must have been very lonely down there.
24 tentacles is better than 6 tentacles, I think.
Thanks for the tomatoes.
Healthy snack.
Oh.
And that thing had...
Yeah, had two dozen tentacles.
I wonder what exploded does.
I was scared though that it was going to explode and kill me.
Right?
It had two.
Two dozen tentacles.
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh, they only send like two out at the beginning.
That's nice.
Okay.
Oh, my God!
We're gaming a little bit.
Oh, yeah, yeah!
Oh, my God!
Oh, one second.
Let me also... select that.
Yeah!
Two tiny rats.
Two tiny rats!
Lots of rats.
Many rats.
Yeah, yeah.
Assassin rats.
Okay.
Hey, that was pretty good though.
We took out... we got some hits and we took out some stuff, so...
Oh, gosh.
Not good.
Okay.
All right.
Keep taking out those platforms.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
And come up here, rats.
Yes.
A little rat party up here.
Did he squish the rats?
I think he squished the rats.
He just took them out.
I'm grazing.
No more rats, baby.
Yippee!
Oh, uh...
Am I supposed to use my floaty here and...
I'm grazing.
Just like Toho.
Graze bonus.
Nice.
Oh,
come on.
That's so cheap.
Wait, can I shoot?
Oh, wait.
Just kidding.
I would have to switch to my gun, I think, maybe.
Hold on.
Let's see if I switch to it.
Oh, it does work!
Oh, dang.
Okay.
Well, there was an attempt.
Oh.
Why does he keep going over there as if I can join him?
Oh, and I can't even... I can't even reach.
I can't even reach.
Come over here, you coward!
Nice.
Okay.
Dang.
Where are you gonna be at?
Oh, wait.
Once I'm running away, maybe it'd be good to use this.
Dang it.
Never mind.
There was...
I nearly had that thing dead, but then my luck turned south.
The old flamethrower?
If I say exploded, will I die?
You guys, will I have to do the fight all over again?
It exploded.
Exploded?
Due to a gasoline leak.
I'm never trusting you guys again.
You know what?
Get off the screen.
You disgust me.
You're not worthy of being on the stream anymore.
You must have been very lonely down there.
Yeah, I absolutely goddamn do!
You assholes!
Why do you bully me so much?
I thought maybe if it exploded, I...
And that thing had...
I could like... what's the word?
I could like... throw it at it, you know?
And do mega damage.
And two dozen tentacles.
DD Mega Doodoo.
And tokko.
And stopping them.
Why do you get stressed over one thing only?!
I really like how this boss is trying to fight against her.
Shut up.
THANKS FOR I don't want to hear your SASS!
Yes, I don't want your sass at all.
What are you saying?
One guy-ing?
As if...
As if the whole chat wasn't being like, Oh, try exploding it.
Try exploding it.
What do you mean, what?
Oh, shoot.
One guy-ed.
Oh, yeah, totally.
The whole chat wasn't saying, Hey, try exploding it.
It'll help.
Bullying tax.
Yeah, I need that.
Oh, look.
He already destroyed it.
So, no more rats.
Easy peasy.
He already destroyed the platform.
Let's go.
And it's quite...
It's quite large, so...
Like a large area of walking.
So I think we're good.
Yeah, it was a lot of guys.
It was a lot of guys!
You can't say one guy-ed.
Don't destroy platform, please.
No more, no more.
I got my guns ready.
And by gun, I mean...
This thing?
Actually...
Oh, wait.
I think I can shoot another one.
Close enough.
Okay.
Um...
Let's...
Thank you!
You're not doing me any favors being over there, Mr. Tentacle Man.
Monster... thingy.
Nice!
That was close.
I forget that I should...
Dang it!
I always miss the mark there.
I nearly had that thing dead.
But then my luck...
It broke apart.
It bro...
Broke apart as I continued the fight.
Okay.
So I finished it the old fashioned way.
With my fists, baby.
Oh, wait, huh?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
My fists are not working.
Boss defeated.
Yippee!
No thanks to you guys.
Boss defeated.
And I don't have my cool...
My cool flamethrower anymore.
My turquoise lover.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh.
This one is not great.
Wait.
This one's really hard.
Um...
What?
I have to be like super speed.
Oh, gosh.
Mr. Fox, the gallows noose.
Tell me how you got it.
I'll tell you later.
Enough.
You've tried my patience, Mr. Fox.
Tell me right now how you got that damn noose.
Or I'll kick your ass and throw you in isolation.
Okay, okay.
No need for that.
I was just about to tell you.
Yeah, tell me.
Broccoli?
I asked Mike, the prison guard, to make a noose so I could hand myself.
And he brought me one, thinking I would do it.
That's all.
What?
What about the broccoli?
Oh.
Broccoli?
What are you talking about?
My apologies, Mr. Fox.
I think I mixed something up.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Is that really- How you got the noose?
Of course not.
I lied to the officer.
Now we get it.
Because no one threatens me to tell the truth.
How did you really get the noose?
I'll tell you later.
Oh, my god.
We'll never know.
Oh, there was a second secret?
We missed it.
How many chapters are there, by the way?
Oh.
Oh my gosh!
Zanzibar Land, for real!
Oh, nevermind.
We're not in Zanzibar Land at all.
A guard!
Oh, he's asleep.
Paradise Killer?
Ever played it?
I haven't.
Wait, if I break this apart, he's gonna wake up!
I can't go back.
Here we go.
Shh, you didn't hear anything.
You heard nothing.
You heard absolutely nothing.
Give me whatever you got.
I'm robbing you.
I'm robbing you blind.
This place has been ransacked...
by a spooky...
ghost!
There's lunch money.
Yeah, I took it.
In the beginning...
I didn't know exactly where I was.
But I knew for sure I wasn't outside.
Are you sure?
Now that I could get a signal...
Oh!
Calling the Colonel crossed my mind.
Yes.
But I realized I didn't have much to report.
Oh.
Speak of the devil.
Son, do you copy?
Copy, Colonel.
Are you my dad?
For the love of God, where have you been?
I thought you were dead.
As I said, Colonel, there's no signal in the sewers.
Yeah.
Give me a SIDREP, son.
My report.
After crossing a mile of smelly, mutant-infested shit-streams...
fighting thousands of rodents...
and nearly being torn apart by some shredders...
Yeah?
I managed to get out of there...
and I'm still in this fucking military base.
Don't lose your marbles, son.
You have plenty of night time...
and they don't know you're located...
Jesse is not as level-headed as Snake.
and get the hell out of there.
Just don't forget the documents.
We need to find out more about Operation Jericho.
I got it, I got it.
If I make it out alive, will you write me a recommendation letter?
If you make it out, we'll give you a damn purple cross.
Over and out.
We managed to avoid shredding.
I have no doubt that the Colonel worked for the government.
Why is that?
Because.
The only thing that old bastard did...
was demand.
Demand.
Let's see, what about, uh... Mikey?
Robert.
Still there?
Yep.
Hey.
How did they catch you?
Yeah.
I was in the outskirts of Katsala.
Taking some pictures of a bunch of military trucks.
There was too much security.
They were obviously hiding something.
I couldn't clearly see what they were loading.
So I got closer.
Turns out, I got too close.
You kissed him.
Next thing you know, I was surrounded by a bunch of pricks.
Aiming rifles at my head.
Did you at least manage to see what they were loading?
Sure did, but...
I was disappointed.
What?
It's like a mix of...
Concrete.
Kazuhiro Miller and, uh...
An Otacon.
Two huge rectangular concrete blocks.
Each could barely fit into a truck.
You were imprisoned for a piece of concrete?
Fuck, man.
I'd be disappointed, too.
Too much security for something so mundane.
But enough about me.
You should get back to your escape, my friend.
It's...
You know...
The lion's death.
Too many Chili Peppers here.
Man, that's the...
That kind of concrete, you know?
Alright.
We emptied our potty.
Oh!
We got a second potty!
This is why you vandalize everything, you guys.
Vandalism is the way.
No, we have two potties.
Two potties.
We're thriving.
Exit!
That surely is the real exit.
Okay, I'll bring you guys back on screen again.
Sorry, I forgot to.
You guys are welcome back.
As long as you behave, you know?
Now you did.
Oh dang it, he caught me though.
Ugh, he caught me.
She likes us.
She loves us.
I'm tolerating it.
She tolerates us.
That's why you vandalize everything.
Vandalism is the way.
This has got to be the exit.
That looks like an exit to me.
Oh, I think we should go through the exit.
I think I think.
What?
Oh, is it because he noticed me?
Oh man, I thought I was going to take care of the job.
There it was.
The exit.
Oh my god, I'm leaving with my new pet.
Sergeant Roscoe's security card didn't open the door.
So I had to search for someone who would lend it to me.
Oh.
Okay.
Good night.
Let's...
Let's see.
Pick him up.
Oh shoot.
I need you to pick him up, please.
Oh,
it doesn't really matter if we get experience.
Oh, my experience.
How did you miss?
I don't know.
That's the game.
There, right in front of me, was the sickbay.
We're going to see a hot girl in there.
Walking through that door changed everything forever.
Oh, yeah?
What's going to change?
It's him.
It's the prisoner that hit us.
It turned out that all the guards I knocked out were brought to the sickbay.
And some were still there.
Oh, my god.
Don't move or I'll shoot.
How was I right about a hot lady?
I surrender.
The woman that was aiming at me was the doctor.
Oh, yeah.
She, of course, was very pissed off because of the copious amount of work I caused.
What a face.
What a body.
What a beauty.
Are we explaining this to our girlfriend?
This girl was smoking hot.
She had a gun straight at my head.
Oh, yeah.
At that distance, I couldn't do anything to neutralize her.
I had to improvise.
Dance, dance.
I needed something that would cause a non-lethal wound.
Like a sharp piece of metal.
But I had to grab it without making a single step.
Oh.
What do I have?
We have a glass eye.
Use.
It wasn't wise to use weapons there.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
I can't shoot her.
Raw meat.
Oh, wait.
Combine with the handkerchief.
And then combine.
Combine this with the gasoline.
Correct.
Combine again.
And then select that.
And then use it.
It wasn't wise to use weapons there.
Dang it.
The coin.
How could I forget?
Oh, wait.
Knock on mine.
Sorry.
Throw the coin.
Oh.
She doesn't want that?
Um.
The ring?
But what if maybe she's like, wait, why do you have these documents?
The first file was about an attack plan.
Its code name was Operation Jericho.
Oh.
We already listened to this.
Um.
Oh.
So it's an attack plan?
Have you ever had a gun pointed at you?
Your adrenaline skyrockets.
You react on instinct.
Everything happened so fast that the doctor had no time to react.
In one swift movement, I took the wire, looked deep within the doctor's eyes, and, took her eyes.
Guys, this is, this is a really hard decision.
Oh.
But we're trying not to kill her, right?
If we do it, if we grab her chest, then she'll... she'll die.
If we do her thighs, she'll just have tetanus.
Her belly?
I think she'll also die.
Let's go for the thighs.
I stuck it in my thigh.
What the hell did you just do?
I just hurt myself.
Are you nuts or what?
Now you can't shoot me.
What do you mean?
You just made it easier for me.
According to the degree on your wall, you're a doctor.
The Hippocratic Oath you took as a doctor forces you to aid your patients.
And also forces you to cause patients no harm.
I've been injured in a sickbay.
Your sickbay.
Therefore, I'm now your patient.
What if I'm forced to assist you?
You bastard!
Yeah, been called that plenty of times.
By the way, I'm bleeding.
Fine.
I'll heal you.
Then you get the hell out of here.
It hurts.
Ouch.
You're done.
It's no longer bleeding.
Oh wow, that was so fast.
Thank you, doctor.
You're welcome.
She's so competent.
Hey, what was that for?
That's for all the extra hours.
I'm working because of you.
It's just as well that you didn't kill anyone.
Kill someone?
Me?
Do I look like an assassin?
After arguing for a while, the doctor and I reached an understanding.
I would not kill anyone.
And she would help me escape.
I haven't killed anybody, okay?
Oh.
There are first aid kits in the closet.
Take some.
If you shoot someone, use them so they don't bleed to death.
Oh.
That's fun.
I can still shoot my...
Quit your yapping.
It
hurts.
Don't speak, Mike.
You have a broken jaw.
Oh, Mike, no.
Try to get some sleep.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
You couldn't just take the card from the pocket?
No, I'm...
Just kill or be killed.
My sight's still fuzzy, doctor.
As expected.
You got hit pretty hard.
I wonder by who.
It looks like your eyes will recover.
I had a doctor.
Doctor?
Hurrah.
It's a good thing I'm such a tip...
Watch out!
Most instruments don't respond well to punches.
Sorry.
It's kill or be killed.
Bye-bye.
Thanks, doc.
Oh, we still don't have...
So this is a red key.
We still don't have the yellow key.
That was the one that, um...
We needed earlier.
Yeah, I'm just breaking everything first.
Oh!
I got some...
Oh, wait.
I got some actual bullets.
Wait, we're gonna get a gun for real?
We're gonna actually be able to commit real crimes?
I finally had a gun.
Now I could kill those guards.
Wait, but I'm not allowed to kill.
That is...
If I were an assassin and didn't promise the doctor I wouldn't murder anyone.
So thanks for the 50 gift cards!
So if I shot someone, I had to use a first aid kit to heal them before they bled to death.
CQC is probably the best way to do it, right?
Of course not.
I'm not an assassin.
Uh-uh.
The gun I found was empty, but it had a 10-bullet magazine.
Nice.
So I loaded it up with any bullets I found.
Which were a lot.
Press R to reload the gun.
...
I'm guessing it's space.
But it's also...
It also doesn't have a suppressor.
So...
I think...
It'll be loud.
Doc, what's the diagnosis?
It's not about the sickness we're given, but it's what we tweet with the time we have.
Doc, my brain rot.
Please tell me.
Lord of the bullets.
What's this guy doing, huh?
What's this guy doing walking around?
Silly ears.
I shot a guard.
I'm sorry!
I couldn't let him die.
I promised it to the doctor.
I had to heal him before bleeding to death.
I'm sorry!
So I got close.
And I used one of my first aid kits.
Oh, see?
You're welcome.
Sorry, I was...
Trying to loot him at the same time.
Okay, let's go get another...
Let's go grab that one from the...
From the cabinet, right?
What a bunch.
Falcon, bye!
Bye!
I think I instinct...
Because of the rat level, I'm instinctually impressing space now.
You know?
Still hurts.
Everything is blurry.
Doc, don't mind me.
Bastard, it's hard.
Rest some more.
I'll check back soon.
Point blank.
Yeah, you know.
Maybe I should unequip the gun.
Yeah, maybe we'll just go back to our little uranium bombs.
I mean...
Uranium bullets.
They seemed a little healthier.
You know?
He's looking around.
He's being a good guard.
This guy is doing the most guarding job I've ever seen.
Such a guard.
Such a good guard.
Yippee!
More bullets!
I mean, the game is just...
The game is basically telling me that I should be a murderer.
I think.
What is this?
This is Jesse Fox.
Over.
This is the doctor.
Oh!
How did she get my number?
Police officer of Jesse Fox sent you a message.
What are you talking about?
Well, my access card won't work.
It's only clearance level two.
Leaving the building requires level three clearance.
Where would I find that?
The officers would have them.
Their offices are on the third floor.
Wow.
Thanks for the help.
I didn't know you cared about me.
She cares about me.
What I care about is that you leave ASAP so I stop getting so many patients.
Oh.
By the way, what's your name?
Oh, yeah.
My name is Doctor.
Over and out.
Oh, Doctor.
Doctor.
I like her.
Oh, hold on.
Colonel.
Do you have what you need to leave?
Not yet, Colonel.
But a contact told me where to find an access card.
A Metal Gear reference?
Yes.
A doctor.
Give me a description.
Hot.
Smoking hot.
Oh, for God's sake.
Control your hormones, son.
We're in the middle of a very serious operation.
You and that libido of yours.
Listen, Colonel.
Make no mistake.
I'm not in any operation of yours.
Maybe I am, Jesse Fox.
Or Miami of your soldiers.
I'm only trying to escape from this damn place.
Damn it, Jess.
Don't you realize this isn't an escape, son?
Yeah, it's overactive libido.
Could end up with countless casualties.
And it's your moral duty as a citizen to prevent it.
A citizen?
I'm just a normal guy, maybe.
Me?
Is that a joke?
Yes, you.
Search every damn office in that building.
For any information you can prevent.
That damn plan.
Over and out.
Okay, well what are you doing on your end then, Colonel?
Oh my gosh, wait, this is an elevator.
Robert, do you copy?
You!
I think I just fell in love.
Wow, seriously?
Give me the deets.
I just met a woman.
Fuck, what a woman.
And wait, did you fall in love with her or just her buddy?
Both.
Hmm.
She hot?
Oh yeah.
You only knew, Robert.
I swear, she's everything I've been searching for.
Wow.
I thought you were searching for a way out.
I need to move.
I'll tell you more later.
Over and out.
He's like kicking his feet.
He's like laying on the ground, like on his belly.
He's like feet in the air.
And he's like twirling his hair.
And he's just like, oh my gosh, Robert.
Robert, I'm in love.
She said the third floor, right?
Hold on.
What was it?
Was it tab?
Oh, here.
Search the officer's office on the third floor.
Okay, yeah.
But before we go up...
What's over here?
Look at these pals.
They're doing their job together.
Hmm.
Which guy should I take out first?
Probably this one.
Nope.
No alert.
Dang it.
That guy caught me a little bit, but...
You know.
That's okay.
What's in the lockers?
Any nerds in here?
Pissy boys?
Nope.
Okay.
Mike!
They're all so concerned about each other.
It's so funny.
What's in here?
Ooh!
This room looks important.
Aha.
Oh yes.
Yes, very important.
Information.
Files!
I got more files.
Nice.
Okay.
The lore?
Yes.
Okay, good.
Before leaving the office, I called Harris to let him know that I found the files.
More files?
Thank you, thank you.
You really are just beating up dudes on their 9 to 5 guard jobs.
I mean, it wasn't that Metal Gear 2?
Colonel, do you copy?
Copy.
I found more documents.
Yep.
They look like...
A list of coordinates.
Coordinates?
Coordinates of what?
This document is encoded as well.
I don't know what the coordinates are for.
Coordinates?
It could be strike targets.
Dun dun!
Those bastards could be planning to attack us.
Oh my god!
What do you think, Robert?
Jesse here.
Do you copy?
I hear you.
I was thinking about those big concrete blocks you saw.
Oh yeah.
This place is full of concrete buildings.
Maybe they're building something.
Something new.
Something that requires a lot of concrete.
Why are there so many guards?
Why are they transporting concrete?
I was hoping you would play this since it came out.
Maybe someone sold them something in parts and they're just bringing them here.
Could be.
But what?
Concrete gear?
Thanks man.
Over and out.
No.
You guys.
There's no concrete gear.
It's like a concrete Gundam.
Concrete Gundam.
A condom.
You guys laughed.
Let's go to the third floor.
X.
I did laugh.
Wait.
If we go down down, how down can we go?
F1?
Can we go any further?
No.
Okay.
This is F2.
Good one, Minto.
Thanks.
I thought it was pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie.
Whatever is down there is going real fast.
Oh my gosh.
This is...
Wait.
This is literally...
Wait a second.
This is literally Metal Gear.
Not Metal Gear Solid.
Metal Gear.
Good one, Minto.
Thanks.
Glad you guys liked it.
I'm bleeding out.
No.
Let's go to the infirmary.
Meow.
Okay.
So it saves at each floor.
Good to know.
Let's go grab a little health kit before we...
Um...
Onwards.
There's no doors that we saw that required a level 2.
Right?
I don't think so.
I could spoil their plan, but I don't have any...
concrete...
answers.
Oh, excuse me.
Thank you.
Concrete answers.
Good one.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's go explore floor 3 because floor 2 is evil.
I hope we never go there.
Floor 3.
Floor 2 is evil.
We will not come back.
Alright.
Save the game.
Cool.
What's going on in here?
We need a level 3 card.
Okay.
Thermal sensors.
Yeah, lasers.
Those thermal sensors had a detection angle of 90 degrees.
And it would sense the heat of my body like the predator.
They obviously wouldn't detect through the tall brown boxes in the facility.
Yeah.
So I could hide from them like how I've been sneaking around the guards.
But the containers weren't everywhere.
Yeah.
Any wide open areas were a problem.
That joke really cemented his existence.
That's what I thought to call the Colonel.
Where I'd learn a way to trick the sensors.
With a box.
No way.
Is it box time?
Colonel.
Do you read me?
I'm on the third floor.
This is where the offices should be.
Should be.
Search for more files.
We need more intel about the attack.
That's not going to be easy.
Yeah, there's sensors.
Those offices should be empty.
Haven't seen anyone yet.
But there's a thermal sensor.
Yeah.
I can't proceed without setting it off.
We got a box.
Do you have any ideas?
In the army we use insulating suits to conceal our body temperature.
Insulating suits.
Oh.
Okay, that was abrupt.
Um, Robert.
You know any insulating suits?
Oh.
Robert, you there?
Okay, bye.
Jesse here.
Over.
Doc.
Oh, never mind.
Robert, you here?
Yep.
Um, is there a suit?
In here?
Where can we go find a suit?
Oh, that's right.
Level three.
Um...
The other floor...
Oh, sorry.
I keep acting like I have to...
Wait, can we go up?
No.
I keep...
The other floor, the one with the drone, it looked like it needed a key.
We can test it, but I don't think we can go through it.
Oh, just kidding!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Oh, that was close.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch.
I ran right into it.
Oh, my...
My, my, my, my, my, my, my, my.
Holy cow.
Oh, gosh.
I can't get hit anymore.
Oh, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die for real.
Don't hit me.
Uh-oh.
Uh, guys?
Oh.
We're fine.
I noticed a few abandoned crates that were thirsty for some punch.
It seemed easy to reach.
That is, until the containers started to drop.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait!
We saw this thing earlier!
Oh, my gosh.
Ah!
Yes?
Oh!
And we're at full health!
How perfect is that?
I think I'm cheating the system.
Let's go back to our gun.
And let's use that instead.
I noticed a few abandoned crates.
Megadron.
Have you guys ever seen that clip?
Oh!
Sorry.
I should pay attention to the shadow.
Have you guys ever seen that clip of the lady on the news?
I noticed a few abandoned crates that were thirsty for some punch.
Trying to say this other person's name, but she calls her DD Megadoodoo.
I think about it way more often than I probably should.
Ah!
Maybe I don't attack it.
Maybe I just have to get...
Oh, never mind.
I do attack it.
Uh...
Well, that's not very good.
Okay, we are...
We're out of space.
We're like slowly...
We're slowly losing space.
I'm out of gun!
I don't think we're gonna make this.
I didn't go up high enough.
Out of gun?
Out of gun!
Maybe we start with the left side.
Or I mean the right side, right?
Left side, right side...
So maybe we get him to drop over here, right?
No!
You're ruining my plan!
You ruined my plan!
Oh, wait.
But how do I shoot him then?
Can I shoot him while he has the crates?
I wonder.
Yes, we can.
Shoot before he drops it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's switch our gun first.
And...
What was the plan there?
What are you talking about?
Oh!
Oh, was I dead?
I guess you're right.
Can we punch those?
I don't think so.
We have to like Tetris...
We have to like Tetris this a little bit.
Okay.
No!
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Okay, I think we got two in.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
I can't...
Okay, you can't run and reload, you guys.
Just letting you know.
In case you were curious.
I tested that theory for you.
So you don't have to test it, okay?
I noticed a few abandoned crates.
Run!
Okay.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
That was close.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, here's where it's gonna start getting...
A little tricky.
Okay.
We're almost there.
Oh, reload.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Yippee!
See, my plan worked, you guys!
Boss defeated!
See?
I reached level four!
Tiger lunge.
You may press X to instantly close the distance and punch enemies into containers.
Cool down between rolls is halved.
I think the tiger lunge is probably better for me.
You can roll... I don't roll that...
I don't utilize the roll very much, so...
I think we're gonna tiger lunge.
Press X.
Whoa!
Sometimes...
Maybe there's a cool down on it.
Because some...
Oh, see?
Like...
Wow!
It's kind of awesome.
Moshi moshi!
Doctor!
What's that, Doctor?
Of course for you!
Of course!
Are we...
gonna tell our girlfriend about this, or...
What are you talking about?
Not that I care, per se.
But I'm getting a little overwhelmed here.
Oh.
Sorry, Doc.
Doc, I just learned tiger lunge.
I'm sorry, I cannot.
You're drooling.
What?
Oh, sorry.
Her voice was so damn sexy.
Is my voice not feminine enough for you?
Well, it's girly, of course, but...
Oh, shut up.
Continue your story.
He's telling everything!
He's...
He's saying all this about...
What?
Okay.
Del, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Doctor, I just learned tiger lunge.
I don't think there's a way that I can make things a little...
I don't think there's a way that I can make things less violent, you know?
Oh, we're going back into the sewers.
What's this?
Antithermal?
Antitherm... wait.
Oh, yes, we need that.
But I don't want to go back through the...
the way we came.
Wait, this is a secret lab.
I climbed down into a pokey little room that seemed to be stocked with a lot of chemicals.
A pokey room?
I could brew up some chloroform to put the guards to sleep.
And score points with the doctor.
Oh!
Hold on.
You have expertise in chemistry?
Chemistry's not that hard.
Oh, yeah.
Of course not.
You just have to mix the ingredients correctly.
That's why I...
you know...
Oh.
Please get degrees anyway, you know?
It doesn't matter what I passed with.
I passed the class.
We got a little bit of sodium!
What else we got here?
A little bit of water.
More sodium.
Yeah, we need that.
Mm-hmm.
More chloro.
Oh, we got the form!
Okay.
More chloro.
More form.
Oh, just kidding.
Let's make it so they can't do any more little experiments down here.
Mm-hmm.
Before leaving, I mixed the elements to create chloroform.
Oh, yes.
Um...
Three parts chloro.
One part form.
Chloro, chloro, chloroform.
Oh, wait.
That's it?
What's a water sodium?
Oh,
that works!
Is that how that works?
The ocean is just one big bomb, you guys.
The ocean is just one big bomb waiting to explode on us.
Water plus sodium.
That's the wa...
Yeah, the water is the dangerous part, you guys.
Water.
Not even once.
Okay?
Sodium is not salt.
Um... I think it is.
Oh!
Oopsie.
I just made the...
Now I made the salt!
Salt water.
Oops.
I made salt water.
Anyway, um...
Chloro...
What is this?
There we go.
Chloroform.
And salt water.
What's the salt water gonna be for?
I don't know.
Whatever we feel like it.
Whatever we feel like.
A guard with his back turned was listening to music.
Yeah.
It was the perfect chance to test out the chloroform.
Yeah, I'm gonna... I just needed to sneak up and put him to sleep.
Okay.
You guys, I'm gonna put the chloroform on my fists, okay?
I'm gonna put the chloroform on my fists.
Okay,
you actually failed.
A guard with his back.
Okay.
Um, what do I see?
Wait.
I wonder what this smells like.
What this smells like?
Hold on.
Are you telling me that you sniffed the chloroform?
That you yourself made for the purpose of knocking people out?
He just walked away.
Why didn't you douse a handkerchief and cover the victim's face?
Like how everyone does.
Oh yeah.
My mind was cloudy at the time.
Maybe due to the fumes from mixing those chemicals.
As for pouring the chloroform on a handkerchief, I figured it out later.
Of course I...
It smells weird.
Goodnight.
Very...
Weird.
Oh.
What's happening?
What the hell?
I can't move.
Oh!
He's wiggling!
No!
The medal!
I didn't know!
Where did he put the medal?
Doctor!
Hold on.
I'm gonna eat my onigiri.
Oh!
I need to untie you.
Don't untie me.
As you wish.
Oh!
Doctor!
Oh wait.
Hey Mike.
This guy's talking in his sleep.
He's asking for a doctor.
Must be a nightmare about a previous injury.
Soldiers with PTSD get them all the time.
He must have been through some shit.
Poor bastard.
I don't know Mike.
Look down.
What the fuck?
He's harder than whiskey.
Oh my god!
Don't laugh at me!
We're close to the cells.
Let's get him locked up.
Fuck Mike.
He's waking up.
Uh oh.
Wait hold on.
I'm eating my...
Hold on.
I'm eating my onigiri.
Oh.
I'm bleeding out.
Um...
Can I go back up?
And get that um...
That metal?
I forgot it.
He's harder than whiskey.
Whiskey is a hard liquor.
Wait.
Yeah yeah.
Is this correct?
Oh.
Oh wait.
What floor?
Oh.
It was floor two.
Wait.
We have to go through the robots again.
Don't we?
Oh shoot.
I see him.
Oh.
My bad.
What is this place?
Wait a second.
I didn't notice this before.
Interesting.
I discovered something real quick.
You guys.
Don't think I can get through.
Box puzzle.
But I can only move one box.
And I can only move it in one spot.
I think it's uh...
More so...
Coming out from that end.
How do we find?
How do we get to that though?
Eeeeek!
Run!
One last shot for safe measure, right?
No!
What can I...
It told me to press X.
Oh.
On what though?
On this?
What is it telling me to press X on?
Oh.
Let's try to figure it out.
Let's see.
Hold on.
Well now we know not to go that way.
So...
Sorry.
I know this is a lot for just a medal.
But it's important to me.
Okay?
Please understand.
Pshew!
It's important to me.
Oh!
Press X did it again.
If I see it, I'll try and grab it.
Yow!
Yowza!
Thrashing all over again.
I don't even know...
What you're talking about.
Down here?
Maybe we can get more stuff for more Chloroform even.
Never mind.
I destroyed the lab.
Combine...
with the Chloroform.
Oh yeah!
Keep space pressed for 3 seconds to put the guard to sleep.
You can move a guard while you put him to sleep.
Oh.
While I put him to sleep?
Hey!
Good night!
And we got it.
Auto-generated experiment.
Quality ma- Oh.
Viewers are laughing at a character in the game named Mike, who is dreaming he has a solid snake.
Viewers are referencing a character from the Metal Gear series who is also named solid snake.
Snake...
Bullet slide!
Oh!
Will you get more bullets maybe?
Very good.
Oh!
Wait!
This might be the room that we saw earlier.
Yup.
Good.
We need more...
I was gonna say we need more bullets, but I guess I was gonna say we need more bullets, but I guess not.
Wait.
How am I supposed to...
How am I supposed to kick it into here?
Wait.
I don't think this is a puzzle.
Oh wait.
You can go down one more?
Oh.
It's kind of hard to tell with the depth perception.
You're right.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's a little hard to tell with the depth perception.
Okay.
Cool.
Let's go upset!
Actually, let's go grab some more health kits.
Because I'm paranoid.
It's okay to hit it.
Just a box!
Just a box.
Yeah.
It's my streamer brain.
I'm so sorry.
And also sicky brain.
Please understand.
Sicky brain.
My onigiri is so good.
Oh my gosh.
It's just a tuna mayo, but... Oh my god!
There's so many of you guys!
I'm sorry, Doc.
Doc, I'm so sorry.
There's so many guys.
Hahaha.
Oh!
Sorry.
Hahaha.
Everything hurts.
Doc, it was a misclick.
I promise.
My hand lashed out on its own.
I think it's possessed.
I stole it from the sewers.
Hahaha.
Yeah, that arm is me.
You might be wondering how I got here.
Okay, third floor time, baby!
Third floor.
And we're gonna put on our little sneaking suit.
And we still don't have the third key.
Yeah.
So now we know two doors, at least.
Was there any more?
Can't remember if there were.
But at least two!
A shiny, delicate, fragile suit used for heat-related tasks.
Like I put this on, right?
Am I wearing it?
Is it on?
I knew better than to punch while wearing the suit.
It was delicate and could tear.
Bad news, no punches while wearing the suit.
Good news, scoring more points with the doctor.
Hahaha.
In what way?
Why?
A battery?
Okay.
Dang it.
Major.
He can't see.
It can't detect me from here, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're in a little office room.
Destroy!
More files!
Colonel!
What is it, Fox?
Colonel, I discovered a third document.
Good job, son!
What's on it?
Let me take a look at it.
Interesting.
What was your name?
Colonel Alan Harris.
Why do you ask?
Because your name is written here.
Don't pull my legs, son.
I'm serious, Colonel.
It's right here.
The tuna just fell out of my onigiri all over my hands.
This means that they need me for their plan.
My hands have mail.
Hahaha.
Why is it so messy?
Hold on, I'm going to wash my hands real quick.
Hold on, guys.
BRB.
Actually, I'm going to make some tea, too, since I don't actually have anything to drink right now.
Wait, is that what I do?
I have a smoothie!
I've been drinking a lot of veggie smoothies.
I'm going to try and combat my sickness.
Here you go.
Wait.
Can I go to the bathroom real quick?
Hold on, guys.
I've got to pee.
I've got to go to the little ghosty's room.
Hold on.
Let me equip the potty.
Okay.
Give me one second.
I, like, just washed my hands.
Now I have to wash my hands again.
Dang it!
One second!
Wait,
my tea!
Wait a second.
You guys, I'm forgetting everything.
Okay.
I'm waiting for the water to boil.
I turned on the little kettle.
I should have turned it on when I got up for the bathroom.
But I'm an idiot.
Okay.
La la la la la.
Let's...
Oh my gosh, it's already almost 2 p.m.
Let's finish this chapter!
How many chapters did you guys say there were in this game?
I can't remember.
How many chapters were there?
Six?
And what?
Oh wait, we're on level...
That's level four.
Um...
Oh, wait, ten?
Ten or six?
More battery.
Yeah, we're on chapter three.
Oh gosh, I'm not making very good progress.
Uh oh.
Um...
Guys?
Ah!
Um...
Uh...
I didn't think the thermal would see me.
It's okay.
That was...
Oh wait, let's destroy the rest of the room.
We must destroy everything first.
Good luck with Unmetal and your health.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Okay.
As long as we get that.
Uh, my...
Well, let's just finish up this chapter and then I guess we'll see how...
How...
Oh, wait.
Oh, this is like a real puzzle, isn't it?
Huh?
Oh.
Do you think it can see me here?
Does a slingshot work on...
On crates?
On
crates?
What about guns?
Do you think it...
I think it will see me at this crate over on the right here.
I guess we'll just try it though.
Oh!
Just kidding.
Hahaha!
I got another battery.
What are these batteries for?
Oh!
Oh, I thought it would hide...
I was behind the other crates!
Oh, these crates don't count, I guess.
Okay.
Good to know.
These crates don't count.
Just the red ones count.
It's okay though.
Those crates are too short.
Yeah, clearly.
Okay.
Let's grab that battery.
Let's put on our suit.
Okay.
Zachart!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
So, don't...
Don't risk it.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Don't get greedy now.
That's what's in here.
Another office!
Oh, sorry.
I'm like covering most of the screen here.
A map!
Alpha building map.
Alpha Kenny.
Wait, wait.
Just in case.
Into?
Oh.
The doctor?
Guard?
Ship?
Doctor.
We ran into doctor.
Doctor, right?
Two detectors!
Oh, just kidding.
Oh.
Is this possible?
Yeah.
Nevermind.
Hahaha.
Can I take this out?
Is this...
controlling all of them?
No.
Okay.
Hahaha.
Who are you?
Oh!
I didn't see them up there!
Hold on, mister!
Save me!
Mister, save me!
You wouldn't shoot your comrade!
Hahaha.
I got so distracted by the guy.
Redo and try S-H-S-H-P?
Why?
It won't let me redo it.
This is the save point.
What does it show?
What does it do anyway, though?
Ahem.
A bunch of sheep?
Hahaha.
Oh.
I'll have to look it up online.
Hello!
You scared me!
Yeah.
Yeah, me neither.
My name's Mike.
And you are?
I'm Mike.
Maintenance.
Mike Maintenance!
But our damn officer kept me here the whole night fixing stuff.
Mmm.
What an asshole.
I'm gonna kick his ass so hard, he'll drop his level 3 access card and be stuck in this building.
Where's his office?
Hahaha.
Really?
Wow!
It's right behind you.
That's the door.
Okay.
The one with the lasers.
Deadly lasers.
That you're gonna deactivate for me.
Well, maybe another time then.
Hold on.
If we generate a small power surge, in the right circuit, those lasers will shut down.
Great.
Let's do it.
I'll need at least 12 batteries.
We keep them in the boxes on this floor.
You get the batteries.
I'll prepare the surge.
Wait, how many batteries do we have?
We have only 4 batteries!
We need 12 of them?
We need 12 of them!
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm trying to eat my onigiri, but try not to get it everywhere on me.
Hahaha.
Um...
Hmm...
This is... this is a good one.
I ate too much of myself.
This team.
Hmm...
Um...
If I choke, I know how to do a solo Heimlich removal.
I'll build a car with them.
Hmm...
More batteries.
More batteries!
Well, this one... wait.
From here, it can't see me, right?
Yeah.
Okay, we're already at 7.
Nice.
Hmm...
I don't think we can get this middle one.
Can we?
Oh, wait.
Maybe from here.
From right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
That's 8?
Um...
Hmm...
I think we can get this top one up here.
Nice.
9...
Could we maybe?
You think it's risky?
You think it's risky trying for this one?
Bottom one too?
Wait, in here?
Oh, wait!
We can get this one right...
Wait, though I think this is a...
Yeah, this is bullets.
Um...
Save before you try?
Yeah, let's try that.
We have two parties, so you know, whatever.
Oh my gosh.
I almost just ran out.
Did you guys see that?
Okay, uh...
No.
Oh, come on!
Come on!
No, shooting the boxes doesn't work either.
What other ones can we get?
Wait, maybe I can stand on the...
side here.
You know, like against the wall.
Like this, kinda.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
And then maybe I can also punch this one.
Nice!
Okay.
Eleven.
One more!
One more, you guys.
One more, one more.
Um...
Maybe I can stand...
here and punch one of these?
Maybe
I can stand...
This one had nothing, so...
Oh!
Don't come here!
I'll take at least one of you out...
before I go!
Okay, uh...
Okay.
This one.
The top box.
Yeah.
Um...
Okay.
That's one.
We just need...
two more.
Which there were... Oh!
Was it the ones in here?
Yeah, this should be good then.
These two.
Yippee!
Okay.
We're all...
good.
We're gouda.
Okay.
Hello mister!
Yeah Mike?
I got you, Mike.
Okay, Mike.
And...
Oh!
His hair!
...
Oh wait, maybe he never had any hair.
Oh my God, they just...
...
They just, they became, yeah, so flaccid.
The office door.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Uh-oh.
They're not talking about our buddy Mike over there.
Mike Maintenance, huh?
Why can a level 2 access card come in here?
Mike Maintenance.
Oh no.
Yeah.
Damn, Robert.
It looks like you're in some big shit, pal.
Oh no.
I've been listening to some radio comms and does the doctor sound familiar to you?
The doctor.
Fuck yes.
Why?
Because I heard that someone is going to arrest him for treason.
That's my girl.
I have to stop them.
No, doctor.
Be careful, Fox.
Don't panic.
This shot could be a trap.
Robert's call made my head spin.
I left the office as fast as I could.
It took me less than two minutes to reach the sick bed.
Oh no.
Dang it.
Oh, okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
Understood.
Okay.
You guys are blocking the timer, but there is a timer.
Oh.
Yep.
Oh, shoot.
Wrong way.
Gosh.
What do you mean the doctor's a guy?
What?
We're running.
Running.
Oh.
He said arrest.
What is happening here?
What's going on here?
Wait.
What do I do here?
Oh.
Gosh.
No!
Oh.
Maybe I have to lure them out.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Uh.
The game is trying to foil my plans.
There we go.
Okay.
We have to probably like coin them out or something.
Um.
Wait.
Will they?
Oh.
Maybe they won't see because of the box though.
What else do we have?
We'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out once we're there.
I'm sure.
Fish and mail.
Yeah.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Um.
The molotov.
That's what I was thinking.
But.
They see me immediately.
So.
It's kind of hard to throw it.
I think.
I was hoping that I could lure them down and take them out without causing an alert.
You know?
I will try the coin.
Just cause.
Okay.
Never mind.
Hahaha.
Um.
The molotov it is, baby.
Wait.
How do I use it?
Oh.
This stream inspired me to commission something.
Oh golly.
I'm scared.
What are you going to commission?
Hahaha.
Oh gosh.
See.
There we go.
Okay.
I kept punching.
It's not punch.
It's space.
Just like with the gun and stuff.
That's my streamer.
Hahaha.
I raised her.
I raised that streamer.
Hahaha.
Ah.
Okay.
Run.
No.
Okay.
They're still here.
Oh my gosh.
Punch.
Oh.
I can't punch in the thing.
How do I...
Go inside the door?
I don't have the key card for it.
Oh wait.
Unless...
This one.
Nope.
No.
We don't have the level 3 key card.
Oh my god.
Nope.
We can't shoot boxes to destroy them.
We've already tried that.
Uh.
Other doors.
There's other doors?
Check around the office.
Okay.
We'll check around the office first.
Let me see.
Because I don't want to alert them.
You know?
Oh.
Punch.
I don't think there's anything really in here you guys.
I don't think so.
Uh.
Let's see.
Is this a vent?
No.
Oh my gosh.
Good thing he didn't turn around.
He would have noticed I'm a fake mic.
We only have less than a minute.
We're not even going to make it.
Let's see.
We can use this time to discover any other possibilities.
What was in here?
Uh.
Another room that I ransacked.
There's a vent somewhere that lets you skip the blockade.
This one?
No.
I can't go through there.
Okay.
Oh.
I can't.
While I'm wearing it, I can't.
While you're wearing it, you can't throw the ball at Tom's either.
Yeah.
Let's radio and see.
And maybe advise.
You sound exhausted.
What's the sitrep?
I'm heading to the sickbay.
They're about to arrest my contact.
Stop it.
It could be a trap.
What if it's not?
I have to help her.
She is expendable.
There is no vent.
Oh my god!
Who's trying to one-guy me then?
Someone's trying to one-guy me.
For real.
Nothing you say is going to change my mind.
For god's sakes, don't rush in blind.
Oh my god.
Take extreme caution.
Someone's actually trying to... trying to...
To one-guy me.
How dare you.
How actually...
How dare you just spread lies on the internet.
You have to have the dev come in and correct your dumb ass.
You're just wrong.
You skipped one room.
This one also has nothing in here you guys.
And I will prove it to you.
There's nothing in here.
Okay.
Take it off.
Taking it off.
Molotov.
Space!
Run!
Why is there going to be so many guys?
The beeping is driving me insane.
I'm going to turn it down just a little bit.
Yeah!
Blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Punch, punch.
Oh, shit.
Punch, punch, punch.
I'm going to bleed out and die.
I don't think this is possible.
The map?
Oh.
Wait, was that beep coming from inside the game?
I don't know.
Actually, the map.
Where are we?
We're on F3.
Yeah, we have to go the whole way.
We have to go around.
Because we don't have the card key.
So.
Yeah.
There's no other way.
We just got to go.
What's the yellow box?
I think that's documents, is it not?
Right?
I think that means documents.
Like the files that we got.
Oh.
So.
Nope.
No, no, no, no, no.
Shoot the guards and avoid alert by being real quick with the shooting part.
Okay.
Maybe the molotov is not the answer.
I thought the molotov would also destroy the boxes too.
But...
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Nice.
I wonder if...
Let's see.
Okay.
Shoot.
Oh.
Oh, I have to heal them.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, you guys are so needy.
You guys are so needy.
Oh my god.
Here you go.
Needy, needy.
There's always time to loot.
Okay.
Now we shoot again.
Ouch!
Dang it.
You know what?
Oh, no!
We'll just shoot everybody!
Just shoot!
Oh.
Including me.
Ahhh!
No!
Why is this harder than any of the bosses that I've gone through this entire time?
Oh, wait.
I think I still have it on.
Okay.
Run!
Oh my gosh.
Mike is not gonna know anything, you guys.
It's okay.
This is...
You just have to go through it.
There's nothing else that you gotta do except just do it.
This Mike doesn't know anything.
Run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
There's no secret passage in the office.
No, no.
You need a key card.
I don't think people are watching the game before commenting.
I don't think you guys are properly opening your eyes.
You know?
It's okay though.
Let's just attach this while we're at it.
And boom!
Boom!
Okay.
Punch, punch, punch, punch.
Punch, punch, punch.
Okie dokie.
And you too.
Okay.
And this one, I have to be like hella quick.
So...
Run!
Punch!
Okay.
I'm also bleeding.
So, first me.
I'm the more important one.
And I'll get you guys.
I'll get you guys.
Okay.
Let's go.
And down.
Are there more guards?
Please, I know.
Oh, let's reload too.
Before I continue onward.
We only got 40 seconds!
Okay, okay, okay.
30 seconds!
Please, potty.
Oh, you know what?
You're so smart.
Just kidding!
No, relaxation!
Oh my gosh, 25 seconds.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
No!
There they were.
Robert was right.
Those bastards were going to arrest their own doctor.
Oh my god.
Sons of bitches.
I wasn't going to let it happen.
Yeah.
I'm going in blasting!
We did it!
As I got close, I could hear shouting from inside.
Then I remembered what Robert told me about being careful.
I held back my urge to kill.
And listened to the conversation.
We're listening.
Why did you give him your access card?
I didn't.
He took it from my jacket.
But you did nothing to stop it.
This is high treason.
You're in deep shit, Dr. Hoffman.
Hoffman.
Dr. Hoffman.
I'm surprised, Mr. Fox.
You managed to remember a surname.
Well, I had a neighbor named Hoffman.
Big German man.
Very hairy.
He was planning to retire, but his gonorrhea had other plans.
What?
Fascinating.
What does that imply?
Sure.
Where was I?
This is high treason.
You're in deep shit, Dr. Hoffman.
He had to keep working because of his gonorrhea?
Good.
Just testing if you were listening.
Stop a man that knocked out all your guards?
Are you really that stupid?
So true.
Dare insult my intelligence.
Speak your truth, truth queen.
I know you gave him medical attention.
How many wounded have you healed, Lieutenant?
I'll tell you.
None.
Why?
Because your job is to be a paper pushing butter bar.
Mine, on the other hand, is to heal and attend.
To anyone who needs it.
Shut up, you guys.
Even if that doesn't heal my family.
Aiding the enemy in this base is treason.
My oath has no restrictions on who I must heal.
You want to arrest me?
Then tell me, Lieutenant.
Who is going to save the lives of your soldiers if I'm in a cell?
You?
A man so incompetent that a prisoner is running circles around him?
How dare you?
Now stop pestering me and get the hell out of my sickbay.
This isn't the end, Doctor.
You're on thin ice.
Oh, she's on thin ice.
She's one badass doctor.
Yeah.
Hide!
Going in was not a good idea.
Oh.
What?
Oh, okay.
I made it.
And off he went, taking the level 3 card with him.
You're so rude!
I needed that card if I wanted to get out of this building.
But before that, I had to check if the doctor was okay.
See if the doctor's alright.
Doc?
Doc, you good?
Doctor, are you alright?
Why do you ask?
I found out you were going to be arrested.
So I ran here to help.
But I heard people shouting.
And I saw those men walking out.
That's Lieutenant Marcuson.
All bark and no brain.
I can't stand that moron.
Really?
I couldn't tell.
But once he speaks to General X, I'll have some serious problems.
You've dragged me into quite a mess.
Sorry, Doc.
I didn't mean to cause you trouble.
Yeah, I know.
Anyway, thanks for worrying about me.
It's what I do.
Plus one experience.
That Marcuson has a level 3 card on him.
I'll understand if I see him in my sickbay later.
You read my mind.
See you around, Doc.
Hang on.
What is that?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Ouch!
Deja vu!
What the hell were you doing?
I was leaning in for a hug.
With your eyes closed?
And you said kiss out loud.
Sorry, let's never speak of this again.
I'm by me.
You look tired.
Take these first aid kits.
Oh, she loaded me up!
Thank you, Doctor.
If you shoot him, don't let him bleed to death.
I'll be executed as an accomplice if he dies.
Now go.
Catch him before he exits the building.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
I think that was negative Riz.
No!
Oh no, no, no!
We have another timer!
Oh my god.
Oh, that was fast.
Isn't the slippery, cowardly pet of that traitorous bitch Are you trying to call me like a slippery creature?
Something that like slides around?
I'm in charge of enforcing curfew.
You try to grab it and it just like slides out of your hands.
Really slippery Slytherin.
There are too many hideouts for a mutt like you.
Python Pete.
Now it's just you and us, mutt.
You can't run and you can't hide.
Oh!
Lieutenant Markison!
Oh my god.
Wait!
No, no, no!
That's not what I meant to do!
You can dodge bullets by rolling.
That's such a good thing to say.
Skip, skip, skip.
That was so fast.
I think they can...
I think they deserve it.
I'm not gonna lie.
Whoa!
Me doing that saved my butt.
Me like saving them?
I dodged his bullets because of...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh my god.
Can he follow my blood trail?
Ouch.
Come on.
He's fast.
He's really fast.
You're a tough little mongrel, aren't you?
I wonder if old dogs can learn new tricks.
What are you gonna do to me?
Let's see you chew your way through lasers.
Lasers?
What lasers?
No!
Luckily the cabinet in the sickbay was full of them.
That doesn't help me very much.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Oh god.
Okay.
I'm just gonna have to let those guys bleed.
If I let them bleed out...
I'll probably get a bad end.
The doctor will be so mad at me.
Punch the guards.
Yeah, let's do CQC instead.
Let's do CQC instead.
If I can.
Skip, skip, skip.
Okay, and V...
I gotta move my placement so that I actually die.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
Oh my god.
That wasn't... that didn't go very well.
That didn't... that didn't go... okay.
I moved my fingers over so I was pressing C instead.
Okay.
Don't do this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Perfect.
This guy is so tough!
Because he's so fast, you know?
Okay.
He's so fast!
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
You're a tough little mongrel, aren't you?
Yeah, I am.
Something lasers!
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is unfair.
This is so unfair.
I would have died otherwise.
I was trapped.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, whoops.
I'll take it.
Oh gosh!
How did you see me?
I hate that just one bullet and I'm like bleeding.
There's no point in me taking the chance.
Gosh!
He sees me so fast!
He turned around!
Like, immediately!
As soon as I...
As soon as I was there!
Oh my god!
Well,
everybody.
Those guys, they just didn't stand it.
They just weren't cut out for, you know...
You're a tough little mongrel, aren't you?
Oh.
No!
It's a game over if somebody dies!
Oh my god!
Clearly, we don't even end up with the doctor!
Don't worry!
Oh my gosh!
No, no, no, no!
His shot is so fast!
I swear!
His bullets are faster than mine!
His bullets are faster than me!
You're a tough little mongrel, aren't you?
Lasers!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, that was so close!
I have to just keep my distance at all?
Sometimes!
Oh my gosh!
Yippee!
Somehow we made that!
Somehow we made it!
No!
Yippee!
You won't be able to beat us!
You will lie here on the ground until someone finds you.
Everyone will know that a single prisoner defeated you.
You will be severely injured.
This guy can bleed out, but you know?
No!
We can ran-sack him, give me a second.
Let's grab some bullets.
Let's... let's reload.
Not the woman.
Father's time!
Thanks for the five-gifter!
Let's take his card.
Yippee!
Leave the building.
With the doctor.
Yeah, we even had medkits left over.
You're still fuzzy, doctor.
That's expected.
You got hit pretty hard.
Doctor, lean in close.
My fight... I mean, my sight is still fuzzy.
My sight is still fuzzy, doctor.
I can't see anything.
I can't even speak, doctor, please.
Heal first?
I guess I should heal.
Yeah, yeah, let's heal and then we'll grab that extra one that I left in there.
Doctor, lean in close.
So I can see your face clearly.
Doctor, my ears are also fuzzy.
It hurts.
Doctor, come in close, doctor.
Can we actually just... oh yeah, there's the exit.
I completely forgot about this.
We just left this guy in the corner earlier.
I tried to open the door with the level three card.
And?
But the exit also had a biometric scanner.
No!
Which needed to scan your retina and your fingerprints.
Let's just go grab the guy.
In other words, only authorized people could open that door.
Let's go...
And I was not one of them.
Let's go grab that guy.
Press X twice over a guard to carry him.
Oh, you press it twice.
Is that how it works?
Let's go grab him.
Come here, give me your fingerprints.
I wish I still had that arm with me.
There we go.
I thought it was like a weird way of...
Okay, so just press X twice.
That's why it was sometimes working.
Wait.
No!
Wait!
The other doors!
Do I get to go back in?
I might be able to go back in.
Let's see.
Chapter four.
Welcome to the jungle.
I might be able to go back in.
I could finally breathe some fresh air.
Hold on.
The ground was untended.
Uneven grass covered the soil.
And the jungle was relentless.
Everything was dark.
Save for a light above the door.
Such immersive storytelling.
Oh, we cannot go.
Well, sorry guys.
I thought...
I truly thought that I...
I don't know.
I thought like...
I thought something was going to happen where you'd be like, Oh, dang it.
I got to the door and I actually couldn't go through it.
And, you know, I thought something like that would happen.
My bad.
No, I am fully aware.
I missed the level three doors.
But it's okay.
It's no biggie.
But...
Yeah, I think that's where I'll end it today.
And I will...
I already have it on the schedule.
When am I continuing?
Let me see.
When am I...
Let me go to my Twitter.
On Sunday.
Sunday, Sunday, Sunday.
We will continue.
Same time, same place.
We'll continue...
This?
I don't know.
I don't know if we'll beat it or if we'll get close to beating it since we didn't even get halfway through.
I don't know if the...
If...
Like I said, load last potty.
Wait a second.
How far along...
Wait, that was a long time ago, wasn't it?
You guys, the last potty...
Nevermind.
I think the last potty was a long time ago.
Otherwise, I would've checked it.
But that's okay.
Yeah, pre-boss fight.
Yeah, it was a...
I don't remember the last time I used it to be honest.
It was a long, long time ago.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
It's when you were getting the batteries.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It was.
And so I would've had to do the chase, the timer again and everything.
But yeah.
Thank you.
This freaky phantom disappointed that Kurei wasn't at Nintendo Direct.
I can't even imagine them showing off something like that in the Direct.
Thank you, Chai Princess.
Try to remain calm.
I'm afraid Sunday also makes it nine years since the Phantom Pain release.
Nine years.
That's crazy.
The game is almost a decade old and still holds up so well.
That's so ancient.
I was going to say that's so awesome, but I almost said ancient.
Have a minty rest of your day.
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
It was really stinky, so it was nice to just watch you play a silly game.
Yeah, have fun!
Yeah, I'm going to go because I'm going to shower and then I want to go out and do some stuff before the typhoon comes.
I don't want to be holed up in my room for a long time.
I have plans this weekend.
I'm really hoping that the typhoon doesn't ruin my plans, but we'll see.
Hopefully not.
I'm keeping my fingers crossed.
Otherwise, I'm going to be so sad because it was part of the only reason...
Well, it wasn't part of the only reason.
But it was part of the reason I came to Japan was for my plans.
So, if it gets cancelled, I'm going to be very, very, very sad.
Thank you guys for all the donations.
Thanks for all the super chats.
Thank you!
Thanks for the fun stream.
Thank you, thank you!
But, you know...
Life happens, I guess.
Or afterlife happens.
For me, in my case.
Asumita!
Thank you guys!
And I'll see you guys next time!
Bye-bye!
See you!
What's happening tomorrow?
I have a schedule!
You should go check it!
Yeah, yeah.
I think for Holocure, it'll probably be delayed one hour.
At the least.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
Check my schedule if you want to know what's going on.
Okay!
Bye-bye!